- Welcome to the doujin
episode of Trash Taste.
- So what you're about to witness
is probably going to be an edited version,
or at least there's no doujins
that we can possibly show on screen
since a lot of the material
we are going to be covering
is going to be very explicit.
- Yeah, we're gonna be talking about it,
but you won't be able to see any of it.
So if you'd like to check it
out and also support the show,
then make sure to go over to our Patreon,
patreon.com/trashtaste
- Where you'll get to see
all the panels on screen
when we talk about them.
- [Joey] Exactly.
- So yeah, if you wanna jack
off while watching Trash Taste,
now you can.
(all laughing)
- But if not, then grab
yourself a drink and-
- Or if you're just
doing it anyway, welcome.
- Welcome. You can just
jack off to us I guess,
but please don't. Please don't.
- Let's get on with it.
(chill wave music begins)
- While you open the wine, Garnt,
- [Garnt] Okay.
- I will explain
what we're doing today.
- This is going to be a wine episode
because we're going to need the
alcohol to get through this.
- I'm drinking pangkor juice.
- We've been drinking a while
on Trash Taste 'cause I feel like
we've been filming earlier,
but yeah, essentially
I don't read doujins,
as I've expressed before-
- No, no, you don't read.
- I don't read,
I don't read, full stop.
- At all.
(all laughing)
- And preferably, I do not
like my porn to be reading.
(all laughing)
We can get into that.
So instead we decided the boys
have both recommended me
three doujins each to read,
and a little bonus one.
- And then we are going
to end on a very special one
where I'm sure people are
going to be excited for-
- So in total we're
gonna talk about seven?
- Yeah, we're gonna be
talking about seven doujins,
or the doujinshis.
- Six doujins
and a mess, "Metamorphosis."
(all laughing)
Which we'll get into.
So yeah, and there's a
little special thing going on
where I don't know whose is which.
So I've been recommended six-
- Do you have like no clue at all or?
- Like I think, some of them I know,
some of them I know.
- I thought some were pretty obvious.
- Some are pretty obvious.
- Some was very, very obvious.
Damn you needed two shots
of vodka there, Garnt.
(Garnt laughing)
Damn, okay.
Some are very obvious. Some I don't know.
And throughout this, I
will be guessing as well
whose doujin was which recommendation.
- Well mostly, though,
mostly though, this show is
going to be just watching
me and Garnt just enjoying
Connor's reactions
to our recommendations.
- And I assume you both read
each other's recommendations.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yes.
- It's funny because we recommended
three doujinshis each, and
I remember giving the list
to Joey and Joey gave his list
and we were like, damn, we
both recommended doujins
that were like 200 pages long, at least.
And we were just like, "Connor, it's cool,
you don't need to read it all,
just read like three
chapters or something."
- Yeah, until you get the
general gist of it, right?
But then Connor was like, "Bet."
(all laughing)
- I'm like, "First of all,
where do I even read doujins?"
I don't even know where you go.
I was like, "I'm totally confused."
- I mean, there's lots of sites out there.
- And then I look for the sites, you know,
and it just gets to the
point where I'm just fighting
for my fucking life to get
the shit on full screen.
There's fucking pop-ups
every two fucking seconds.
I'm just trying to do my
homework and I gotta worry
about fucking hot single
ladies in my area.
You know, like.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
It's terrible.
- You'll get used to it, man, don't worry.
- So, how long did it take
you to read everything?
- I was under the impression
that doujins were like 30,
40 pages.
- No, a lot of them are. That's the thing.
- I mean yeah-
- How did you guys manage
to find all of them
that were like 200 fucking pages?
- Because those are the best ones.
- Those are the best ones, yeah.
- And yeah, I remember you saying,
"Oh, you know, just stop at one chapter."
There was never any
breaks in these things.
So I couldn't just-
- What do you mean?
They all had chapters.
- Not that I saw when I was reading.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I don't know where
I was reading them.
- When it says, at the end of the chapter,
it says like "Ending"
- Yeah
- Or like, "To be continued."
Or something like that.
- But I also feel like that,
you know-
- Some of them literally have a whole page
that says "Chapter two."
- I did not see that,
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
but I read them all.
- Jesus Christ.
- So I'm gonna tell the
names of these doujins
which again, still mean nothing to me.
"Dorei Usagi To Anthony"
(both laughing)
What?
- White man butchers Japanese.
- "To Anthony."
- What is it, Anthony?
(both laughing)
Is that what it is?
What is it, huh?
What is it?
I don't know!
- All right, go on, go
on, go on, what else?
- "Inma no Mikata!"
- Yeah.
- "Succubi's Supporter."
- So you're saying the Japanese name
and then the translated name.
- Oh is that what this is, I thought-
- Some of them have English translations
of the Japanese name.
- "Juunengo No Jinsei Soudan."
(Joey speaks indistinctly)
(both laughing)
"Life consultation after 10 years."
"Pisu Hame!"
- Yeah.
- Very interesting title.
"Seikatsu Shuukan."
- Yeah.
- Kyoushi To Seito To-
Teacher and Student."
I understand that one.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, so, I mean, I just went in order
of which one you gave me.
So I read them.
- [Joey] Okay.
- [Garnt] Okay.
- I read "Dorei Usagi To Anthony."
When should I guess whose I think it is?
- Guess it right at the beginning.
- Why don't you guess it
right at the beginning?
- I think-
- It's a 50/50.
- I think, I wrote down each one.
I think this was Joey's.
- You are correct.
(both laughing)
- And I think because
there was like a loli
for like 10 seconds.
(all laughing)
- I saw the cover, and I'm just like,
"Connor's gonna immediately guess this."
- Yeah, yeah, 'cause the cover
looked like, fucking Shinobu.
Cover looked like this bitch.
I was like "This is Joey's!"
- This was the cover of the main girl.
And I'm just like, she
emanates such Shinobu energy
that Connor's gonna
immediately guess this.
- The first thing I wrote was,
"just from the cover, I think it's Joey."
(all laughing)
- This is literally going to be,
"If it's not a milf, it's
a loli," the episode.
- There were some, yeah. There was some.
- Okay to be fair, this
one, I don't blame you.
This one, I don't blame you.
- She wasn't a loli, she
just looked like Shinobu.
- Before we jump right into
it, what were your thoughts?
Yeah, what were your thoughts
going into just reading hentai?
Because this is like our unofficial sequel
to the hentai episode, I guess.
- Go check that out if you haven't yet.
- It is exhausting reading porn.
(Joey laughing)
- [Joey] Well, I'm sure
it is when you read.
- It's like, if you asked me to like,
okay, if you're horny, you
wanna jack off to something,
you can do it, right?
A 10 minute video or whatever.
If you made me sit
through like a two hour JV
when I'm not horny,
I couldn't imagine like a
worse experience in my life.
- Because how long were you collectively
reading these doujins for?
- Like three to four hours.
(Garnt laughing)
- Well that's because-
- Back to back.
- Well it's because we
thought, right, we were like,
I saw the list and I was like,
all of these are like,
full on like, books.
- Yeah, I read them all.
- So I was like, oh,
okay, so like, you know,
a couple of chapters each,
max take like an hour.
- He just needs to get an idea of each.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Well there's only one of
them I didn't read fully.
It was 'cause there was like, 2,800 pages.
- There was like, 500 pages, right?
- It was ridiculous, so I
gave up on the first one,
but I mean, yeah, it was
just, it was exhausting.
It is really like, I've sat
through really bad movies
that I felt were less painful.
(both laughing)
Like it is just difficult.
I mean, reading doujins, I can see it.
You know, sometimes you see
something like, oh, that's hot.
And then I'm like, even if
I wanted to jack off here,
what am I supposed to do?
Do I just sit there and think
about what I'm looking at?
Like that feels like I'm like de-evolving.
Like, at what point do I just do like
morse code masturbating?
Like, where I'm like,
"Oh dude, that's so hot.
"She's telling she's going
to fuck me in morse."
Like, I don't know, to
me, I like the movement.
I'm not seeing enough movement, you know?
- I'm not seeing enough movement.
- My eyes are not stimulated enough.
(all laughing)
- I don't know, I was reading this
and I just like, every time I
thought this was really hot,
I'm like, "what would I do?"
- What would I do!
- It's not continuing,
I have to continue it.
- My cock in my hand, I
don't know what to do.
- I'm like, "What do I do, dick in hand."
- Stuck in the scene.
- What do I do?
What do I do?
It's not moving, it needs to move.
When does it start moving?
(all laughing)
- This is the exact reaction I wanted.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Even if I thought it was hot, I just,
Some of them, you know, I will admit,
some of them I thought
were quite attractive.
I thought they were very well done.
And if they were in anime form, I'd nut.
- It's weird because like,
some of these have had anime
adaptations, right?
- [Connor] I know.
- But like, to me, like doujin,
the doujin version is always hotter
than the anime version.
- I agree.
- I don't know what it is about hentai-
- Well I mean the drawings
are very more intense.
That's something I learned very quickly.
- I get like a way more intense feeling
from reading the doujins.
No, no because than watching
the anime adaptation, right?
- No, no I agree.
- To me, it's a different
kind of art form, right?
'Cause to me, like
reading doujins is like,
to me it's a really good
way to warm up, right?
- [Connor] Right, right.
- Right.
Because to me, like,
who really likes sitting
through a 20 minute hentai, you know?
That's-
(both laughing)
- I don't mind. I haven't
got time, you know?
- I mean, most of the time
I'm just like, whatever,
but for some reason,
in stories in doujins,
I'm like, "I'm listening, go on"
- After you read it, Joey.
- Yeah, I'm reading, I'm invested, go on.
- To me, reading doujins
is just getting the story,
you know, getting the context
and being able to get the
story without having to like,
just watch 20 minutes of
just boring buildup in porn.
- And it's so much hotter when
you understand the context
behind the scene.
- It is, it is.
- I mean, I speed run the story
most of the time anyway.
Like if it's like this,
you know what they're doing
it's, all right, yeah, go on.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Tap, tap, tap
ten seconds forward.
I get it, he's your
brother, all right, okay.
(both laughing)
In a laundry machine, oh no.
Let's skip forward on that, okay.
I've got enough understanding
of the plot that I can go now.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Right.
- I can do it, I can enjoy it.
- So, did you like,
did you like input any of
the stories of any of them?
- Yeah, no I did, I actually liked,
'cause obviously when you're reading,
it's really hard to ignore the story.
- You can't double tap.
- It's pretty, really frustrating.
- You couldn't skip the cut scenes.
- You're like, "what am I doing wrong?"
(all laughing)
- I feel like, this is
a fatal flaw of books,
you can't skip any of the story, you know?
- You can't skip any of the cut scenes.
You can't just go
straight to the gameplay.
- As much as I tried, trust me.
- All right, so let's start
with the first one then.
- "Dorei Usagi to-"
- Which is the first one
you wanna start with?
Do you wanna go in order?
- I think we'll start with this one.
- "Dorei Usagi," right?
- So this is the one where,
this is a strange story.
And I admit that at
times it was quite hot,
but then it was also really weird.
Really, really weird. So I mean like.
- [Garnt] How so?
- So there's this girl, who's a ghost,
but she's then not a ghost.
I think she's taking
medicine to go invisible
and then she's like sucking
him off in the class
and no one can see him suck. No one.
But she's invisible, but he's not.
So why is his dick invisible?
This is gonna sound really strange.
This was a very confusing plot.
- Oh yeah, so if you care
about reading the doujins,
we're gonna be spoiling it, I guess.
If you care about the plot.
- Spoilers.
(both laughing)
- Spoiler warning.
- This was like, for every
like, in this one at least,
for every one moment that I
was like, "Oh, that's hot,"
it would literally do 10 other things
where I'm like, "What the fuck is this?
What the fuck am I reading?"
- Honestly, 'cause after
you've read everything,
'cause I only, like, I thought
you were just gonna read
a few chapters of everything,
so I read a few chapters of Joey.
And then when you said
you read everything,
I went back to just completely
finished everything as well.
Right?
- Right.
- I feel like there's just
a complete 180 at the end
as well, where it starts going
into this other backstory.
I'm like, "No, no, no,
no. No, no, no, no."
- Yeah, yeah.
That author tends to do that
with everything he writes.
- There was just like moments in there
where I had to write down, it was like,
I put, "This shit is mad incel."
(both laughing)
- Isn't that most doujins?
- That's most doujins.
- Yeah, that's true.
Because there was this
moment where we're like,
"Oh, these girls are wearing
skirts, they're such sluts."
And I'm like, "All right."
(both laughing)
- These femoids.
(all laughing)
- All right, okay, geez.
- How dare they?
- I don't know what I'm
getting myself into.
- I mean, look at the main character.
He's just, he's like,
- [Connor] Yeah, that's true.
- Okay, I guess before we get into it.
Joey, do you want to explain
why you chose this one?
- Yeah, why'd you choose this one?
- Okay, so literally, okay I'll admit,
this was the part where I was like,
"Fuck, I don't know what
to do for the third one."
- [Connor] Okay.
- Okay.
- But I like everything by Akatsuki Myuuto
who's like this artist.
So honestly, any one of his
could have been on this list.
- Right.
- But I figured like,
probably the least weird one
for Connor would be this one.
- The least weird one?
- The least weird one.
- I feel like this is
not the least weird one.
I mean, there's a few other ones.
I mean it's not that bad.
- No, the least weird out of his works.
- Oh, okay.
- Yeah, yeah.
I mean like the other two are ones
that I actually really enjoy.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- That like immediately
came off the top of my head.
- You know, the one thing that
I wish they would just chill
out with on doujins is just
how fast shit escalates.
It goes from like, "uwu," to
like, gang bang in the showers
within like, four pages at times.
And I'm like, "Hold on, hold on, hold on."
- There's no time to fuck around,
there's hundreds of pages.
- Yeah, let this boy chill
her out a little bit,
let him play some video
games, you're like,
"Fuck I just fucked,
you know, like, damn!"
- Well why?
I don't know why you're suggesting that
'cause you're probably gonna skip over it.
- Yeah, I know, but it's
just like, "Oh God, okay,
I'm just gonna-
oh God, we're fucking!"
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
Give me a warning.
- I actually had, like out of everyone,
I had the most trouble
following this story.
- This was really confusing.
- I thought it was like
a really simple story.
And then like, the last
chapter here, I'm just like,
"What is going on right now?"
- Can you, 'cause I'm fucking stupid,
can you explain the basic
premise of the story?
- From what I-
(Garnt laughing)
- Which again, it's, from what
I understand, this guy was,
okay, so again, I won't spoil the thing,
'cause you find out more earlier on,
but we'll start from the start.
You just kind of find this guy,
kind of like a normal incel,
kind of, I mean I feel like,
- Basic hentai protagonist.
- Wants to get revenge on
all the women around him
and then a girl transfers into the school
who then immediately
just starts, is a ghost,
but starts fucking him.
- So, only he can see her,
but no one else can see her.
So she gives him glasses or something?
That, makes-
- That's right.
- Yeah she gives him some glasses.
- That make all the clothes see-through.
- Yeah, that make all
the clothes see-through.
So he's just looking at
all these naked girls
while being sucked off
by this invisible girl,
even though no girl can
see him being sucked off?
- Yeah and also this girl
immediately starts sucking him off
like, right away.
And then, I hate it when they do this,
when they refer to the characters,
when they refer to themselves
in the third person to me,
I'm like, "Stop that, what is that?"
- Is that what they did?
- Yeah, they did that
only in the first scene,
and I was like, "Oh God, please tell me
this isn't a constant thing."
She's like calling herself her name,
which is Charlotte, I think.
- Yeah.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And she's like "Charlotte
is happy," and I'm like,
"Oh for fuck's sake."
- Yeah, yeah she calls
herself third person, that's right.
Admittedly, it's been a while
since I've read this, but-
- I was hoping you'd bring
more context into it.
- But, okay, but I remember
the reason why I picked
this one is because it
literally has every tag.
- I guess.
- That's what I enjoy about it.
Like you get the best of, I
was about to say both worlds,
every world, every multi-verse.
- It's a lot and so he
fucks the ghost, blow job
and apparently no one else can see.
- Even though he's like
clearly nutting at the table.
- I'm like this guy is literally nutting.
- He's like, ah!
- Are you telling me-
- And she's like, "Are you okay?"
- Yeah, like, as if no one
would notice that you're,
you know, come on, fuck off.
- Yeah, yeah.
- To be honest, that scene
was fucking hilarious.
- It's hard to believe
that it's as attractive
'cause there's no way I could
be like, "Oh, that's hot.
That could be me," like no,
it could never, ever be me.
Not that I would ever
want a ghost sucking,
I don't want a Casper sucking me off.
But you know, it's kinda,
you know what I mean?
- Basically like the first
chapter just kind of reminded me
of like some porn spinoff
of Bunny Girl Senpai, right?
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah.
(Joey laughs)
- Well, you know where he's in the library
and he sees Mai for the first time
and no one else can see him.
This is basically just that, you know?
- This is that if it was R rated.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- I also, I know I've watched hentai,
so I know this shit exists,
but there was one piece
of dialogue as well,
where, like the bully girls
who are like attractive or whatever.
- Oh the gals, right?
- Yeah, the gals,
you know, they ask him for
money and that's so inexcusable
that in return he's gonna fuck them.
That's how he's gonna get back at them.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I'm like,
"What the fuck is this logic?"
Like, "What am I-"
- It's incel logic, dude.
- I know, I know.
- It's incel logic.
- It's like, "Bro she literally
asked you for a tenner.
"What do you mean, chill
out," like, come on.
Like, I don't think it's that bad.
- How dare you?
- Yeah not bad.
Okay, now he become
horny Casper the ghost.
(Joey laughing)
He goes invisible.
- Oh that's right, he goes invisible.
- I was not following the story at all.
- So then what happens
is, is that the girl,
this Charlotte ghost girl, then is like,
"Well, don't worry homie, I got you,"
and starts like drugging the
other people in the class
that make them horny.
- Oh yeah she does do that.
- And then he starts
fucking them and then she
introduces like new power-ups,
this is like the fastest PS2 game.
- That's what I'm saying, man.
Like it's every time.
- And then he's like,
"Hold up, but now you can drug them
and then I'll give you
invisibility drugs."
And it's like, "But you
only got 30 minutes."
And then he starts fucking
like the whole school.
(Joey laughing)
And then they find out,
and then they don't care
and then they carry on fucking.
And then this just goes insanity,
and literally the whole
school is being fucked
by this one guy within like,
I'm literally 10 minutes
into the story and this
is what's going on.
I'm like, I can't think.
What is happening?
Which girl is which?
I don't know which. They
all have the same hairstyle.
Wait a minute, is this girl Robin?
Wait, which one's the,
which one's the ghost?
What is happening?
- No, it was at this point where like,
you know, when there's like
so many girls that all of them
just start blending in together,
- Yeah, yeah, yeah
- and you were just like,
I don't even know who
you're fucking anymore.
- Yeah, right?
Like, you know, and then where the fuck
did this Willy Wonka candy come from,
where everyone's just fucking horny now.
What does it come from?
Where's the backstory to that, you know?
- There's no backstory.
- And then later on we
find out that the main girl
who he wanted to fuck the
whole time was some poor
homeless girl that he was
speaking to in the start?
- Oh, the student council girl.
- Yeah, that he got made
fun of for talking to
and then the girl wishes
that they'd never met.
Or he wishes that he never?
And then his doll, his doll comes to life
and that's the one he's fucking,
and she brings the drugs.
What is going on?
- That's what confused me.
It was that chapter where
the doll starts talking
and I'm just like, "Have I
just skipped over a chapter?"
- This is literally like
"Lord of the Rings,"
when you miss like one page, you're like,
"Hold up, did I just miss the whole,
did I miss the whole story?"
- You missed the whole
point of the story, yeah.
- I need to go back 20 pages.
- It feels like I just
got a Shyamalan twist
without having a Shyamalan movie.
- Every page is a Shyamalan twist.
- I can't keep up with it.
I'm just like what is going on?
But like, there'll be like two moments
where I'm like, that's hot.
And then what is going on?
- Okay, okay, what I didn't understand
was, okay so, was the main girl just,
was she wearing a wig the entire time?
(overlapping laughter and chatter)
I didn't understand.
- She's like a bald bitch.
It's like, "My weave!"
- He shows up at this
house and he's just like,
what's the girl's name again?
- I don't know.
- Charlotte,
- Charlotte.
- He's just like, "Charlotte?"
And it's a girl with black hair
and then Charlotte fucking runs away
and starts putting on a wig, right?
- Yeah, yeah, no, wait.
- [Garnt] Am I following this correctly?
- Wait, wait, what, I don't-
- This was like the second
to last chapter, right?
- I thought he was just
like, you know what,
I honestly got very
confused reading this one,
I'm not gonna lie, there's multiple times,
I re-read this ending like four times
and I still didn't understand
what was happening.
And then like, they just
pull like, you know,
he literally, it's just the sheer,
like, how it just
changes, like completely.
It literally ends on like a gang bang,
and then the next panel it's like,
you could hear the Anohana
music playing inside.
But really, there's a sad backstory
as to why he's fucking everyone.
It's like, "Oh, get the fuck
outta here, what is this?
I don't give a fuck. No one cares."
- Not gonna lie, I chose
this one because I knew
you guys would react like this.
Because it's so ridiculous
that I just love it.
- Like, you know, that
shonen trope where like,
the villain gets defeated,
and then after the villain's defeated,
you finally see his backstory?
That's like, that doesn't
belong in a hentai.
- [Connor] That's exactly, yeah.
- You can't just fuck a girl
and then just show her backstory
after she gets fucked, okay?
Like, I need this context
before the fucking happens.
- It's like, putting a backstory
in the middle of a fight, right?
It's just like, why now, why now?
You couldn't have waited until afterwards?
- I'm not gonna lie, some
of these are blend, no.
It's blending into my head.
And it would just end.
How does this one end?
- It ends with this random
fucking side story of someone-
- With the marriage?
- With the marriage.
- I was like,
"What is happening?!"
- And I'm like,
I didn't recognize any
of these characters.
- None of these characters look the same.
- It wasn't even the
main fucking character.
- But they just fuck, they
just fuck for some reason,
even though he just cheated
right before his like,
wedding day or some shit?
- Yeah, oh yeah, he did.
- He like, cheats right
before his wedding day.
Like the whole story is like,
they're a fan club of him, I think.
They're a fan club of
the ghost that fucked,
like the main protagonist, the incel guy,
they make a fan club of
him in the side story.
But I don't recognize
any of these characters.
- [Joey] No, no.
- And then two of them
are getting married and-
- And it's not even the main girl either.
- [Connor] No it's got
nothing to do with them.
- It's a different girl.
- And then he cheats on
her, right before the day of
and then there's a whole scene of,
"Does anyone object to the marriage?"
And they were like, "I do."
(all laughing)
It's like this shit is insanity.
I didn't even know what to critique.
- I don't regret raising this one.
- There's just so much shit
happening, that I'm like,
what do I even begin to critique?
Because there was just way
too much shit going on.
It's like someone,
he literally pulled up every
genre and he was like, bet.
Like I'm gonna get every-
- Yeah, that's exactly what he did.
- It's like, is there a genre
where it's like, you know,
shout at the wedding,
"no, stop the marriage?"
Is that a tag?
That could be a tag.
- Yeah it probably is.
- Stop the marriage.
- Stop the count.
- Stop the fucking count.
- Stop the marriage.
- My favorite hentai tag, stop the count.
- Stop the, yeah.
(both laughing)
That is this tag, it's
just stop the count, right?
'Cause he's fucked so many girls now
that I can't even count
how many girls he's fucked.
- It's like, to me, you know,
like I said on the hentai episode,
you know, there has to be
some kind of story in there
and there was moments-
- Oh now you care about story, huh?
- In hentai I do, yeah, I
need a little bit of story.
- This man.
- This is the only time when-
- Which is why some of them,
it might shock you that I enjoy later.
(all laughing)
But, like, this one was just like,
"What the fuck is happening?"
It's a dumb ass story.
Shit keeps getting weirder and weirder,
not in a funny way, like that one hentai
where people start shooting
each other and there's dubstep.
There's no dubsteps going
on with these panels.
Dubstep would've gone great
with some of these scenes, frankly.
- [Joey] Oh yeah.
- I wish there was a
built-in like dubstep.
- You could have just gone onto YouTube
and dubstepped as you read it.
- Honestly, this is the kind of, yeah,
it's literally the kind
of doujin where I put on
Skrillex in the background
and it'll be well paced,
like Skrillex.
- Honestly, like, reading this,
I feel like my boner got
whiplash with the amount of shit
that was happening.
- True, true, true.
- You're just like-
- Your dick got a workout after that.
It's like, up, up, up, up.
- Every time you're like "I'm into this,"
it's like, no, no.
- No, no, okay.
It's like you start getting
into it, nope, new tag.
Okay, well I guess I'll just,
nope, okay, new tag, okay?
And I'm just like, okay,
what is the theme to this?
What was the author's vision?
- What was the vision?
What was the author
trying to say with this?
- This is literally,
what tags do you want?
Yes.
This is what this is.
- It's terrible, it's fucking terrible.
- I know to me, it needed like, it needed,
okay, this is gonna sound
so fucking pretentious.
It needed something to
connect all the dots, right?
(Joey laughing)
- No, I honestly I'm gonna agree with you.
- Oh my fucking God, are we
agreeing on something, Connor?
My fucking God.
Trash Taste first.
- This felt like, just 10
doujins that have been like,
let's just fucking ram them into one.
We got these sexy girls
that I don't wanna redraw
in different ways, like,
shove 'em into one.
- You know what this felt like?
This felt like it was like, if the MCU
had one recurring character
in every movie, right?
But then it was just like, it
was one continuous narrative,
but because every movie genre
is so fucking different,
you just don't know what
the fuck's going on.
You can't follow anything.
- It's like playing all
the MCU movies at once.
- I gave this one a,
I originally wrote down seven,
but I that can't be right.
I'll give it like a five really.
- Oh, we're doing scores as well?
- I would have given it,
personally I give it a five.
- Is this one got an anime adaptation,
like a hentai adaptation?
- I don't think so.
I don't think anything by Akatsuki Myuuto
has gotten an anime.
But I mean, if this doesn't-
- I don't even know the authors.
- I guess, before we move on though,
what did you think of the art?
- It's fine. It's pretty good.
The art's pretty intense,
I mean, I feel like there's
a lot more fluids going on
in the doujins than the anime adaptations.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, the art, it's pretty damn good.
I mean, I can't fault that, you know.
- Yeah the art was good, the art was good.
- I don't think there
was any of these, doujins
where the art put me off except-
I liked all of them actually.
I'd say all of them had their merits.
- That's good.
- So like in his other
works, you said this one
was one of the least weird ones, right?
- Yeah.
- What's so weird about his other works?
Well what happens in his other works,
if you can remember.
- Fuck.
- And Ashley, can you put on
the air conditioning right now?
'Cause I'm getting a bit heated.
(all laughing)
- It's getting hot in here.
- Literally and,
like mentally and physically right now.
- So there's another one.
When I was like thinking of
what the last one is, right,
I was like, all right, let me
go through my favorite artists
and see if there's one I can remember.
And then I got to his works.
And one of them I wanted
to recommend was one called
"Lingua Franca" which is also done by him.
And again, this is a while
since I've read this one.
But basic, over simplified
premise is guy and a girl
flying a plane across an island
and they crash land onto said island.
And that island has
this secret civilization
of all these like Amazon-esque
girls who live there.
- Is this a "Futurama" episode?
- And the guy gets kidnapped
by that civilization
because he's the first
male that they've seen
in like over 100 years.
- Is that literally,
this is literally-
- Death by Snu-Snu.
- Yeah this is literally
the "Futurama" episode.
- It's literally Death by Snu-Snu.
- Oh my God.
- But then you find out
there's like this alien species
that has been controlling
that civilization
for the longest time.
- That's "Futurama." That's literally-
- Is it?
- Yeah, there's a robot controlling them.
- I do not remember that part of the-
- That Bender like, makes out with.
- I can't believe "Futurama"
ripped off Akatsuki Myuuto.
- It's literally a Futurama episode.
- I can't believe "Futurama'
ripped them off like that.
(both laughing)
Cease and Desist incoming.
- I mean if you had to give this a rating,
what would you give it then?
Top of your head.
- Eight.
- Eight?
- No, I'd say like six or seven.
- Really?
- Yeah, it's good but it's
not my favorite of his.
- I think the best part
of this was the art.
- Yeah.
- The ending and the fact
that it ended, honestly.
(laughing)
- The ending just made me confused.
- I don't like it when they put a one shot
with totally different
characters that's like 10 pages.
That just confuses me.
I'm like, "Wait, should I be,
Wait, what's going on?"
- Oh, the bonus content, yeah.
- I hate it when they do that,
it confuses me to death.
- Well, that's like the
bonus content you get
from buying the full book.
- [Connor] Right, right right.
- Rather than just
reading it in magazines.
- Yeah, I'll give it a five.
It was like,
- That's a pass.
- Huh?
- I've seen like a lot of hentai like this
where it's just like,
all right, let's just get
into the fucking as fast as possible.
What is the premise?
All right, premise done.
How many girls can this
fuck in one single sitting?
- Yes.
- Yeah.
And that was just this
hentai. I mean, it was good.
It was good, you know?
- I'll admit, even
though I recommended it,
it's nothing special.
- Okay.
- I just really liked the art.
- You're just grasping at straws?
- No, no, I just really like the artist,
and how fucking ridiculous and like,
just like, his passion
for just being like,
"Finna put every tag that I can."
- I respect that.
- Into one.
It's like, I respect it.
- I respect it.
- All right, what's the next one?
- "Inma No Mikata!" Succubi's Supporter.
- Oh yes, yes, yes.
Which one do you think this is?
- Whoever chose this
knew me well, I'd say.
- [Joey] Right.
- I think I have this as Joey here.
- Okay.
- It's mine.
- Oh, okay okay.
- Wait, you know what?
- This one, this one could
have gone either way.
- Yeah, you know what's funny
is that this is one of
three that I've read before.
And I was gonna put it in
until Garnt sent me his list.
- Dude, it's a classic.
- It's like one of the top rated ones.
- I think it's one of the
most famous doujinshis
like, long form doujinshis of all time.
- I see why.
- And for good fucking reason, like, it's-
- Art is great, story's great.
- Art is great, story's
great, and just blow jobs.
- Very good, very good.
- Like it will blow your fucking mind.
- So essentially how the story
starts is there's just a guy
who doesn't have a job
chilling on a bench.
And then Succubis come up to him.
Kind of like a hot
singles in your area ad.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- But IRL.
They just come up to him and they're like,
"Hey, do you want a job
helping us succubuses?"
And he's like, "Oh, I
don't know what that is,
but okay, sure."
- What's a succubus?
- To give a bit more context,
so this world has like
succubi, or succubus,
have integrated into the human society.
So like they're not this
mythical creature anymore.
So like a lot of most of
the population of the world
has some succubus blood in it, right?
- That's right.
- And the science is that
the more succubus blood
that's in a guy, the less
tasty their semen is.
- Fluids are.
- Their fluids are.
- Garnt, come on, we're on YouTube here.
- Okay, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
- Wake up gamers, because this video
is sponsored by GamerSupps.
- As you all know, we've
officially partnered
with GamerSupps.
- Gamer!
- Why?
The powder tastes great,
it's cheaper and healthier
than other energy drinks
and mixes perfectly.
- Garnt, but in all honesty,
I'm just here for the amazing
selection of Waifu Cups.
- Look at all these beautiful Waifus.
- Very gamers.
- That's how you know how gamer we are.
(all laughing)
My microphone just came off.
As I was saying, all of
the Waifu Cups you see here
are limited edition.
So you should get them quickly
if you think you're a true gamer girl.
- These shirts and cups always sell out,
so if you want your
chance to get your Waifu,
you have to move fast.
- What are you gamers waiting for?
Go and get your Waifu
Cups and support the show
by using coupon code TRASHTASTE.
Buy lots of stuff so we can
get our GamerSupps flavor
and comment what you
think it should be called.
I am being held at gunpoint,
but that's because I'm a gamer
and I play games.
- Back to the show, gamers.
- And of course, our main
guy here is one of like,
one of the 0.1% of the population left.
- That is just pure human.
- That is just pure human blood, right?
Pure, no succubus blood
in this family tree.
And of course the job he
is given is to basically
just like provide an
all you can eat buffet.
(Joey laughing)
That's the best way I can provide it.
- Of dick.
- One man buffet.
- One man versus the world.
- I mean, I liked this one.
It was very good, how can
you not like this one?
- This was one of the
like, least offensive ones.
- What guy wouldn't want this?
You literally, you're just
a piece of meat, you know?
Let 'em just.
- Yeah yeah.
One thing that like,
'cause this artist I feel,
is probably like the
best artist when it comes
to drawing blow job scenes.
I mean, this doujinshi in general
is just 90% blow job, right?
I think there's like one sex scene in it
and it lasts like, two,
three pages or something.
Its mostly-
- It's mostly blow jobs.
- Yeah, yeah yeah.
- Yeah.
So clearly we know what this artist likes.
(all laughing)
- It's like literally the blow
jobs you wish you were given,
like, if I could give
this manga a summary,
it's pretty much that.
I mean, yeah. I mean, what
is not to like about this?
Like I said, like God tier
art, positions are fantastic.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Fantastic stuff.
- Okay, here's a question.
Do you think this would
translate well into a hentai?
- Yeah, dude, if fucking
Pink Pineapple made this?
Hell yeah, dude I'm there.
- Wait, did this not get a hentai?
- No.
- No, they got, "Stayed
at Home Succubus" got one.
- Oh yeah, that's right.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- The other one got it.
- The other one got it, yeah.
- And I don't know, like what I think
wouldn't translate well is that
the fucking blow job scenes
are so intense.
I couldn't see it
translating well into hentai.
- Yeah.
- I might be able to
be done, I don't know.
Maybe science will advance
and we'll get good technology
to be able to emanate.
- Oh I don't know, man.
Like it'd be like a 20 minute BJ scene.
- So yeah, they have this story where,
okay, they just started fucking him.
And then apparently his peepee
is so good that they're like,
"We made a website about your dick."
- Oh yeah, they made him
go viral, didn't they?
They made him go viral.
- They were like,
"Oh, by the way, we've
put your dick online.
"Don't worry, by the way,
we haven't shown your face.
We wouldn't do that."
- Yeah, yeah, of course.
- "But your dick's famous
now to all the other succubi
in the world."
And then like, "Oh, okay,
there's more succubus
in this world, okay."
And then they hold an award
show, not an awards show,
it's like-
- Like an idol handshake.
- A handshake, yeah that's it.
It's an idol handshake
thing where you can come
and instead of handshake an
idol, you can suck the dick.
(Joey laughing)
- Yeah, so these succubus,
they're like hundreds of succubus show up
to this handshaking event where-
- The cock shaking event.
- Yeah, where they pay an amount of money
to get like five minutes
to milk the cow, right?
(both laughing)
That's the best way to describe it, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Pretty much, pretty much.
- That was probably my favorite chapter.
I'm just like, that was one
fucking intense chapter.
- Yeah.
- Just 'cause normally I'm like,
I'm not into like the
whole harem angle of it,
but it was so like the
concept was so overdone
and the art was so great.
And it was just,
- So hot.
- Some of the scenes
were so fucking intense
that I'm just like, "Yo that's hot."
All right, that's hot.
- That's hot. That's hot.
- That's very good, that's very good.
Very good stuff, I'm
just getting flashbacks.
- This is one where it's
like, if I'm suffering
to like, you know, pick one for the job.
- This is like the comfort food.
- Yeah, this is the comfort food,
this is the one that I always go back to.
- I mean, the reason I picked
this one is because like,
out of every doujinshi,
if I were to pick one
where I'm introducing someone
to the world of doujinshi
and what it's like, then
this one's just like
an all-rounder in every category.
- This is the-
(Joey laughing)
- It don't miss. It don't miss.
- This is the fucking
Naruto of Hentai, okay?
It's the gateway drug, okay?
- It's the gateway to doujinshi.
(overlapping chatter and laughter)
- I mean yeah, because the content,
like the tags are so
inoffensive where it's like
it's not too weird where it's like,
"Oh, I'm not really into that."
Like everyone's into fucking BJs.
- Like who doesn't love blow jobs, right?
- Who wouldn't want three succubuses?
I mean that's, I mean, you know.
- This is such a "God I
wish that were me" doujin.
- And it's okay, right 'cause
it's succubuses, right?
So if you nut too early,
that's like great.
They like that, that's what they want.
They want more of it.
(all laughing)
No disappointment. Oh God.
- Yeah, I mean, what I liked
is that they gave context
to you, you know, normally
like a hentai protagonist
can orgasm like an
ungodly amount of times.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Yeah, I liked the fact
that they gave it a reason
for him to be able to
orgasm that amount of times,
which is just like if you feed on the-
- They have pheromones or something.
- They have pheromones, and
if you feed on their spit
or something.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah,
it's always the saliva.
- Yeah, if you swap body
fluids, then it's just
like this fucking mega aphrodisiac.
- And the semen is like an
aphrodisiac for succubi, right?
So it's like a twofer.
- The never ending cycle.
- The perfect system doesn't exist.
- In this story after they have
this whole handshaking event
as I like to call it, they
put his face online anyway.
They're like, "Come guys,
look how amazing this guy is."
And then suddenly a fucking
Sundari loli shows up
and I'm like, "What's all this?"
(Garnt laughing)
- Oh yeah.
- Why are you getting
in the way of my hentai?
(both laughing)
I'm like.
- I totally forgot about that.
- Because I didn't know which
one of you did this, right?
So that was what tilted it in the end.
(both laugh)
I was like "Fuck, fuck come on."
- Oh yeah, this bitch, I remember.
- Yeah, I remember first reading that.
And then she's like,
"Hello, I am the mother."
- Yeah, and then I was like,
it literally the headset meme of like,
taking the headset off like,
"Aw, you had it, you had it!
Why did you introduce a fucking loli??
It was so good!
- No, because what was so
funny is that she's technically
a loli MILF, right?
(all laughing)
- The best of both worlds, everybody wins!
- Literally I wasn't
even wearing a headset,
but I metaphorically pulled
one off for that meme.
I'm like, "Fuck this shit!"
- Just did the movement.
- Fuck!
- It was so, bah, God, it
was so perfect, you know,
I was enjoying life,
it was great, you know,
and then this happened.
(Joey laughing)
It just ruined it for me.
It was great, it was great.
- There's no pleasing,
even with the most inoffensive doujin,
there's no pleasing this man.
- I just didn't like, and she
got her whole own section.
I was like, no one else
got their own section.
Why do you get your own section?
But they do later on.
But at this point, no one
else had their own section
at this point, why does the fucking loli
who just showed up looking
like a fucking Bratz Doll,
get to have a whole fucking 20 pages?
What's this?
I don't want this.
I'm like, fucking speed running this shit,
trying to get it over with.
Like when is anything else gonna happen?
And then luckily, luckily it saved itself.
It brought out the big guns.
- The next thing, the next chapter, right?
- The next chapter, yeah.
- And then suddenly they
introduced, they're like,
"Oh, by the way, there's
a union for succubuses,"
because of course there is
and they have a headquarters.
- Yeah, he gets shipped
off to like the fucking UN
or something, right?
- The fucking UN of succubuses,
he gets shipped off.
And then they're like,
"by the way, succubuses
have been stopping wars
for generations because we
fuck people into submission.
So no wars because everyone is
happy because we fuck them."
and it's like, "oh, okay. I
mean, I guess that makes sense."
- [Joey] Of course.
- Gotta introduce some
world-building somewhere, right?
- Can't have wars if
you're fucking, right?
Geez. And then yeah, I
really liked that woman.
She was great, she was very attractive.
I very much liked her.
- 'Cause she looks like a MILF.
- Hell yeah she does.
I thought she was right up my alley.
I was like, this is great.
- You do look like an office
lady tag kind of person.
- Oh absolutely.
Because she was also, you
know, she was also like,
"Ah, no, I don't want
it, I don't want it."
But then she did want it.
(all laughing)
- That's what I like.
- Out of context Connor.
- No, no, no!
(Garnt laughing)
- Garnt.
- I mean, but it was
obvious the whole time
that they were gonna fuck.
- Yeah, of course.
- We're in a doujin here.
- Wouldn't it have been
such a Shyamalan twist
where they introduce her and she's like,
"Oh, I don't want it."
And it's like, "understandable."
- You know, I wanna watch a
porno where the plumber comes
and just fixes something
and then just leaves.
And then she just masturbates.
You know, I want that.
- That's very avant garde.
- Subvert my expectations,
you know, give me something.
Throw me a curve ball, you know?
- We're deconstructing porno now.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah, but I mean, I think I wrote down,
I said, this would have
been a 10 out of 10
if they didn't have
the fucking loli in it.
(both laughing)
The loli intrusion, as I called it.
- The loli intrusion.
- Oh my God.
- Yeah, I mean, I wrote
the art as God tier.
Like pretty much everything was God tier.
I'm like fucking around
with eight out of 10,
I mean, yeah, it was probably my favorite
out of all of these, in
terms of, could I nut to it?
This was definitely the-
- Yeah. That does not surprise me.
- Despite being just pictures,
I think I could manage.
I think if I scroll really fast.
- The first thing I did
when I looked at the list
with Garnt and mine is like.
- This is gonna be Connor's favorite.
- You guys know my tastes now.
You know my tastes.
- I'm like this man likes
vanilla, this is the most vanilla.
He's gonna like this one.
- I mean, it's not so
much vanilla as so much
as so it's just universally agreed.
- It's inoffensive, yeah.
- That this is God tier doujin, right?
- Oh yeah, 100%.
- It's one of the best doujins ever made,
some of the best art ever made.
Hasn't yet gotten a hentai
adaptation, which I'm just like,
how has this not got a hentai adaptation?
- I would appreciate
an adaptation to this.
I mean maybe all the studios are scared.
- Oh yeah, its like a VIP. They're like,
we don't wanna fuck-
- We don't wanna fuck this up, dude.
- And then Queen Bee
cracking their knuckles
- Dude if Queen Bee adapts
this, I would cry so hard.
- We need to take a shot at this.
- Just comes from from behind the trees
- No, because,
what sucks about Queen
Bee is that when you,
it's like every Queen
Bee doujin that seems
to get adapted is like,
a doujin I respect like,
close to this level, right?
It's a God tier doujin
that gets passed around and
you're like, brilliant, this
looks fucking fantastic.
- I mean, I feel like when I,
when I see people in the
comments of these websites,
being like, "Oh God, it's Queen Bee."
I'm just like, I don't even
know who this doujin is.
So I could have never
been disappointed anyway.
- What is this?
- And frankly.
- I don't even know who you are.
- I literally don't even know who you are,
so like it's not a problem.
Some of them, I still manage.
You know, Queen Bee does a
good enough job sometimes.
- Good enough job.
- Right, and get the job done.
You know, the task can be complete.
But yeah, no, I mean, this is just great.
So I highly recommend if
you haven't read doujins,
go and read it.
- Wow, Connor recommending doujins.
- Wow, what the fuck?
- What a world first.
- You know what I would
prefer Queen Bee did actually,
instead of what they do now?
I would prefer that if Queen
Bee animated their doujins
or animated their hentai
the same way that-
- Animated doujins are made?
- Kind of like a, what was that,
the yakuza husband one that got animated?
- Oh, "Way of the House Husband."
- "Way of the House Husband."
- Like slideshows?
- Yeah.
- Not slideshows, but just
like an animated comic.
I would actually prefer that style over-
- Where they just copy each frame.
- Yeah true.
- Because to me like a motion
comic would give way more
of like an impact than
whatever the fuck Queen Bee do.
- Yeah.
- Like please Queen Bee, please.
I can handle that, just
give me a motion comic.
- Call me Queen Bee.
- How much you need, like 20 bucks?
- 20 Bucks, yeah.
- That's the whole budget.
Yeah, I mean, like I
wrote eight out of 10,
'cause of loli but I
probably give it a nine.
It would have been a 10 out
of 10 if there was no loli.
Honestly I'm not joking, that's serious.
That kind of took me out of it.
I was like, whiplashing.
- Would you be interested
in his other works then?
- Are they this good?
- This one is really good.
- Most of his work is
very blow job oriented.
He's just a fucking blowjob.
- He sticks to a theme.
He sticks to a theme.
- Well, I always think, you know,
blow job is like the best visually part.
Like the visually like sexual thing,
blow job is probably the
most attractive looking,
I think when done right.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- It's like a, what is it, a macaroon?
Those little fucking sweets?
You know where I'm going with this?
You always see those sweets, right?
You're like-
- Are you comparing
blow jobs to macaroons?
- You look at a macaroon, right?
You're like, "That looks amazing.
That looks fucking amazing,
I really, really want that."
And they never, ever, ever
taste as good as they look.
And that's how I feel about blow jobs.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Yeah
- Why?
- Dude, 'cause in fucking-
- In hentai,
- I can feel the salt.
- In hentai, bro, they
make it look like fucking
"Wrestle Mania Smack Down",
whirlwind on the dick.
It's not like that in real life.
It's like, "Oh, shit, ah oh."
- You've been getting shit blow jobs then.
- It that what it's like?
That's not what it's like.
- That's what it looks like
in the hentai at least.
It's very aggressive, very aggressive.
But I mean, it's a lot of
work sometimes, you know?
Sometimes it's awkward
and you just realize
that you're just standing there.
You're just like, "Oh fuck,
it's awkward, isn't it?"
- Oh, so much work, you know?
- It's just like, sometimes,
sometimes like, what's
so great about blow job
is that there's literally
no pressure to do anything,
you know, right?
'Cause you know.
(both laughing)
- But sometimes I get
that moment where like,
I get distracted for one second
and I get taken out of it.
I'm like, "Fuck, fuck I
gotta to do my taxes, fuck."
Now I gotta pretend like I'm still there,
I'm still in the zone.
- Oh yeah.
- "Ah, ah!"
"Fuck! I really got to
file those taxes though.
Fuck, I really forgot about that.
Oh God, I can't do it now, can I?
That's gonna be really awkward
if I go and do those now."
- It's like, "Babe, can you
hand me my laptop real quick?
I'm just gotta file these taxes."
(all laughing)
- It's not interactive enough.
I'm joking, I'm joking.
But yeah, no it was good,
it was good, it was good.
- All right.
- All right, next one.
- It was the, I already
know who this one was.
This is fucking degenerate.
- Which one?
- "Juunengo no Jinsei Soudan,"
"Life Consultation After 10 Years."
Okay, be me guys, be me.
You sit there, right?
I only know, right, I know one thing.
All right, I know the word Oreimo
(Garnt laughing)
right, and I know it means incest.
'Cause I know Garnt likes
incest for some reason.
- I don't.
Guys, as I said before,
Oreimo isn't an incest anime.
- It's an anime with incest in it.
- It's just an anime with incest anime.
This is very much an incest doujin.
- I have not watched Oreimo.
I opened this thing.
- Don't worry, you don't have to.
- It's literally, I feel
like I understand the story
of the anime through this.
Which is very concerning
because, fuck, this is weird.
- Whatever you're thinking about
is probably what happened in Oreimo.
- There is so many things in
this anime that it made me
like, push my desk chair back
a little bit and go like,
"All right, all right."
- Yeah, because this one I
saw on the list, I was like,
"Oh, I've never heard of
this one, I'll check it out."
- Fucking open it up,
just Oreimo fan fuck.
- No, no, no, my one just,
because I read mine in Japanese,
so my one just said
"Juunengo no Jinsei Soudan"
and I was like, "Okay this
one sounds interesting."
First page is literally just like Kirino
with massive tits, I'm like.
(Joey inhales deeply)
(all laughing)
- It's like the biggest like,
(Joey sighs heavily)
All right.
- Okay, I knew this one.
- You did this to fucking
troll, didn't you?
- No, no.
- I know you fucking did.
- No, no, no.
- Don't tell me you like this.
- This is, to me, probably
the hottest like series Doujin
I've ever read.
(Garnt laughing)
- What, why?
- Okay, because like, I
purposely avoided parodies.
- Okay, this I thought we, you know, I-
- Because if that was the case,
I would've recommended
like, three of my favorites
are all parodies.
- Yeah, so this is like the only parody,
like, parody doujin that is on the list.
But like, I didn't know if we
were avoiding parodies or not,
but I just wanted to talk
about this no matter what.
- We can do a parody
episode in the future.
- I mean, 'cause like most parody doujins,
they last for like one chapter,
they last for like 20 pages.
- Yeah, it's like 10, 30 pages.
- This one is an entire fucking story.
- It's like 220 pages.
- I felt like I was on like a fucking
like, "Big Brother" episode,
like where this was,
fuck, it never ended. It
just never fucking ended.
- [Joey] Not gonna lie, I-
- It just kept
getting fucking weirder and weirder.
- With this one, okay.
Admittedly, I don't like
Oreimo, like the show,
but I think Oreimo
doujins are hot as fuck.
- Yeah.
- [Joey] All right.
But here's the thing...
- Why?
- Because all the characters are hot.
- Oh my God.
- But here's the thing, all right?
Here's the thing with this particular one.
I've read a lot of Oreimo doujins.
I've never read this one.
This one, I was like, okay.
First half I was like, "Okay, this got
kind of an interesting story."
Like you kind of get to see like,
the backstory of like
the actual characters.
- It gets real fucking weird.
- And then second half,
like she just like turns
into a yandere.
- Yeah, so can you walk
me through the story?
- Okay, okay.
- 'Cause I had to pull up
the fucking Oreimo Wiki
to understand who the fuck everyone was.
- Cliff notes of Oreimo.
- Because it doesn't
try and fucking ease you
into these characters.
It's like, "You know Oreimo,
you're jacking off to Oreimo."
- You know what you're reading.
- I mean, what?
Okay, so to explain I
guess the basic premise
of Oreimo as well,
so Kirino and Kyousuke is the
main sibling pair rubberized.
And then all you need to know is also
he has a childhood friend
who I don't even remember
her fucking name.
- Oh the glasses girl, Mami?
- The one who's the wife in this doujin.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Not Mami, what the fuck's her name?
- Natsumi or something?
- I'll look it up.
- Look it up, but basically
those are like all you need
to know about the
characters in this, right?
So in the ending of the original anime,
Kirino confesses to Kyousuke,
which was like a 180 twist
from like everything that
was built up before, right?
And then, you know, they
have a few dates together
and then they decide...
- With his sister?
- [Garnt] Yeah, with his
sister, which you know,
they're not blood related, so whatever.
- So it doesn't count, clearly.
(both laughing)
- This is literally, they can't
keep getting away with this.
The know you, they're
like brother and sister,
not blood-related. Fuck, man.
- Oh, shut up, Connor.
- Shut up.
- Look, you recommended
"Mothers know Breast"
that's literally a guy and his step-mom.
That's just incest with
an age gap, Connor.
- It's different, it's different.
- No, no, no, no, no, no it's not.
- She wed into it, it's a different thing.
- Legally, it's different.
- It depends, you know, if
it's like the stepbrother,
I don't know.
I could be like maybe, maybe, but no.
But this one's like, we're literally.
They're literally brother and
sister and this is literally
just like the fucking
card they slither in.
By the way, not blood related.
- God damn, what the fuck's her name?
- What is it?
Just Google. Just Google.
- But this was just fucking weird.
So explain the story of this dude.
- Okay, so I'll explain it.
- Manami, Manami.
- Manami.
Okay, so this is like
kind of like a fan story
set 10 years after the-
- I got that, I understood that.
- Yeah, 10 years, that's
why it's called 10 years
after the consultation or
something like that, all right?
So this is set 10 years
after the ending of the anime
where it has like a
slightly different ending.
So in this version, Kirino and Kyousuke
sleep with each other, right?
And their family finds out and Kirino
just gets fucking banished, right?
And they don't see each
other for 10 years.
- Understandable.
- Yeah.
Understandable, banish
the fuck out of him.
- Parents doing what parents should do.
- Exile your kid if they
fuck your sister, I guess.
- And so, I guess this is
set 10 years afterwards,
where she comes back and
they're both now married.
He has married his childhood friend,
which is like in the anime
her, like Manami is like,
she's built up as like
the plain girl, right?
She doesn't really have
any special features.
- The girl that will probably never win.
- The girl that was never on
the winning list to begin with.
But she's built up as just the plain girl.
She's the childhood friend, right?
And in this version, she's the one
that he ended up marrying.
And Kirino has also
apparently, after 10 years,
married someone else as well.
And this is the first time
they've met after 10 years.
And they think, you know,
they're kind of like testing
the waters to see if
they still have feelings
for each other and it turns out-
- Spoilers, they do.
- And it turns out they do, I guess.
- Who tests waters with
your brother and sister
to see if you still
have feelings together?
That feels like a very dangerous game.
It's like Russian roulette.
- Welcome to the incest tag, bro.
Literally everything in this tag is that.
- What if I just like
put my dick in your hand?
Let's just see if I get hard.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- That's a good test.
- Okay.
- What if we just fucked?
How weird would that be?
- Okay.
So, to explain my tastes, right?
(Joey laughs)
To explain what I,
like, why I thought this was like great,
because for one, most parody doujins,
they just like, it's the most
vanilla fucking storyline
like ever, right?
It's just, here's these
two characters, they sex.
You are watching it
because it's the characters
you recognize.
But this, what I liked about this
is that it took the concept of Oreimo
and it like, built on it and like started
its own fucking storyline.
- I do appreciate that element, yeah.
- It was like, this was actually
a really story-heavy doujin.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I mean, unfortunately,
I couldn't really
appreciate that 'cause I
didn't know fucking anything
about the show.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I was just like, "This bitch crazy."
(Garnt laughing)
- No, yeah, no, I did like
the fact that it built
on the lore of the original
series that it was based off of.
But just it took like a fucking
depressing fucking turn.
- Oh, it was fucking
depressing as shit, right?
- Like Kirino turns yandere and
then like threatens Kyousuke
and then Manami gets like raped.
- Yeah, it's like this whole thing
just kept getting weirder and weirder.
So, be me. I don't know
anything about this, you know?
I don't know anything about this series.
All I know is that he got
banished for fucking his sister
10 years ago, and then they're like,
"Oh yeah, we're gonna meet again. "
Immediately fuck.
It's like, no fucking downtime.
We just made eye contact, we fucking.
Oh, she's like, "I don't even
love my husband, I love you."
And it's like, "Oh Jesus."
- Well, it's because they
both know what they want.
- Yeah, I know, I know
- No words necessary.
- And I guess like for me, if
I were to explain my tastes,
what I find hot is like when
a taboo gets broken, right?
It's like it's not the incest, okay?
- No, I was about to say I'm pretty sure
that's the one reason every person
who likes the incest tag says.
- Well, like what I hate about
most incest fucking hentai or whatever,
it's like one girl says Onii chan, incest.
I'm just like, get that
shit out of here, you know?
I don't give a shit about that.
- So you need the full
backstory of their brotherly
and sister love to be
crushed in front of you.
- Well, it's not just
between like step siblings,
step mother, step sons.
Like I like, you know,
two coworkers who know
they shouldn't get together,
they get together, that's hot.
Like a teacher, student relationship.
That's pretty fucking hot
as well, because it's-
- No, I understand those.
- It's like, what I find
hot is like two characters
who know they shouldn't get together,
but they're too hot for each
other to be able to stop it.
And they do it even though
they know it's wrong.
And I don't know man, to
me, like breaking a taboo
is fucking hot.
- I totally get that, I
think that's hot as well.
But then there's like,
but then there's the scene
where she just goes loony.
(Garnt laughing)
Like she's just loses her mind.
- For every moment I thought
maybe this could be hot,
there's just something
happened where I'm like,
"Goddamn it, this is
vile. Oh, it's so gross."
So there's this whole
bit where he's having sex
with the girl.
- Which girl?
- Uh, there's only two girls.
- There's only two girls, yeah.
- The other girl, the
boring one, as you said.
- The wife.
- Manami.
- Yeah, and then she
pulls out just a strap-on,
for some reason.
(both laughing)
- Oh yeah.
- It just comes out of nowhere.
And it just felt like the DLC
being tacked on at the end.
It was just like this is so rushed in
and half of like one second
and then it was never mentioned again,
it was never shown again.
She just had it with her.
Like it was ready to go.
- You know what I love about that scene
with the fucking strap-on scene?
Where she like puts it into
the wife and she's like,
"It's too big."
And then she's like "This is the same size
as my big brother's."
(Garnt laughing)
It's like, "Was he
never serious with you?"
And I'm like, "Oh my God, that's a burn."
She just got fucking burned.
- The moment, this is a moment that like,
really puzzled me the most,
and I just didn't understand why.
So, you know, he fucks his
stepsister or whatever, sister,
and has this whole thing
and they have this thing
and he cheats on his wife
and they cheat on his wife.
and they have this whole
weird scene where she fucks
his wife and stuff, I don't
really get why that's happening,
but at the end, she's like,
"By the way I told Mom
again that we fucked."
(Joey laughs)
And I'm like, why?
Why did you need to-"
(overlapping chatter and laughter)
Why are you?
- Oh my God, I completely
forgot about that.
- I'm just sitting there,
like, "Did you really need
to just tell your mom that
you fucked your brother again?
What are you trying to achieve here?"
What is this, what is this?
Who does this?
- I read that and I was like,
"Well that was unnecessary."
- And I was like, "Well
this just went too far
because frankly, your mom is
probably just a very nice woman
who just got dragged into this."
- Let's be real, your mom
didn't need to know this.
- Your mom's getting to an older age.
You gotta let her live
her life peacefully,
knowing that you were a
good son and daughter.
- BT Dubs, mom, fucked my bro.
- And then just leaves. And then leaves!
- [Joey] Peace!
- What's wrong with you?
What is wrong with you?
Why did you do this?
I just couldn't fathom it.
It's like, you don't see
this in the, you know,
when you go on fucking, I don't know,
one of these porn websites.
Bang Bros or whatever,
and there's the whole mom
versus son-step.
- Mom versus son-step.
(all laughing)
- There's not a whole scene
at the end where like,
"Okay son, I'm gonna tell Dad now."
I don't wanna see that shit.
Don't include that shit
'cause I already feel
guilty enough for this shit.
Don't include this.
- But clearly this was supposed
to be depressing, right?
- Yeah, it's meant to
be a depressing doujin.
- [Connor] Really?
It's like, if it was
like scat porn the like,
right, "Let's do 10 whole
pages where they clean it up."
Like, no, no let's not do that.
- The aftermath.
(all laughing)
- They're just like,
get the cling film bags.
Get the bleach, we'll clean this place.
No, I don't wanna see this shit.
This felt totally unnecessary.
Why was this in the story?
Like you felt like you had to wrap it up?
How does this wrap it up in any way?
- [Joey] Well to be honest,
- You're making more problems.
- To be honest, like right
before that whole thing happened.
No, no, right before
that whole thing ended,
in my head, I was like, "How
are they gonna end this?"
And then...
- They do that!
- And then that happened.
I'm like, "Well, I mean,
that's an ending, I guess."
That's not the correct answer, but.
- Okay, the ending was a bit weird.
(all laughing)
- Only that was a bit weird?
- I mean like, the reason
I really like this doujin
was 'cause like the first two chapters,
like when it started getting
a bit NTR-y I'm just like,
"Ah, you're kind of losing me here."
- They had us in the first half.
- Yeah they got us in the first half.
- It was because to me,
the first half was so fucking well done
that I'm just like, okay, I'm
always gonna remember this.
- The art was very good.
- Yeah, I mean the art was good.
To me it was the story that was good.
- Art was good and the
way that they broke down
the lore was really good.
- Because it's so fucking rare
for me to find like, hentai
and doujinshi that I actually
give a shit about the story.
'Cause like most like, when
you think of like, for example,
most brother-sister, hentai,
it's the most like simple shit.
- It's like the sister
comes in, wakes up brother.
"Oh, no, you're hard, I
guess I'll suck you off now."
- And I'm just like, like that's.
- Doujin over.
- That's exactly, I'm just like,
- That's literally every incest.
- Who gives a shit about that?
- It's like, cool.
- Okay, no, I've got a perfect thing.
I need spice with my hentai, okay?
(Joey laughing)
Surprise, surprise.
- Incest.
- Surprise, surprise.
- Incest is not spice.
Incest has never been spicy.
It's illegal.
- I mean, that's why it's
always fucking step-siblings
in Hentai, right?
They never go the full fuck.
They never do the full monty, right?
Step-siblings, step-mother.
- You'd be surprised.
You'd be surprised.
- That not the shit I watch.
(all laughing)
- Joey's like, "I can name a few."
- I can name like, 10
off the top of my head.
- I'll tell you what, the
reason every hentai does it
is because it's like that disclaimer,
that goes on like the beginning
of every YouTube video.
It's like "This YouTube
video is fair use."
(Joey laughs)
This video is protected
under fair use. These
siblings are not for,
Your Honor, these siblings
are simply step-siblings.
It is not illegal.
- They're not blood related,
they are just drawings.
Just in case you didn't
hear me the first time,
this episode is sponsored by GamerSupps.
- Did you buy anything yet?
Why didn't you buying anything yet?
But after you've bought your GamerSupps
which you've already
done because you watched
the first promotion and
already bought them.
That's right, yes you did.
But once it arrives at your door,
you'll notice that GamerSupps
is not chalky at all.
- And there's no chemical
aftertaste, did you know that?
You should, because you've
already bought GamerSupps.
- You need GamerSupps.
Get this shit into me!
(Joey laughing)
- GamerSupps is zero calories, zero carbs
and is non-glycemic, so it
doesn't touch your blood sugar,
making it diabetic and keto friendly.
No bullshit, just 100
milligrams of organic caffeine
from green coffee beans
and essential vitamins
to keep me focused
throughout my gaming period.
- God, I'm gaming so much right now.
Guys I have a recommendation.
Might I recommend the
newest flavor, Waifu candy
in my favorite new Waifu cup.
- GamerSupps Waifu cups
for the perfect marriage
between weebs and gamers.
- That's a terrible slogan,
we're not using that.
Back to the episode.
(all laughing)
I am just playing devil's advocate
'cause it's very easy
to make someone who says
"I like incest" look
bad, so it's very fun.
- I mean, I don't know
why it's so surprising
when you're talking about,
Garnt "I love domestic
girlfriend" Gigguk, you know?
- The man knows his tastes,
man. What can I say?
- I know my tastes. Okay, so.
- I respect that.
- Yeah, because to me, like I said,
breaking taboo, that is my taste.
Unfortunately, it's so fucking
hard because 99% of hentai,
when it comes to like breaking taboo,
are just like the most
depraved NTR shit you can find
on like, God's green Earth.
- Why's that shit so nasty?
- I don't know, I don't know.
- Why is there so much of it?
- So many people are into it, man.
- Yeah, you know, you go
onto the hentai releases.
And nowadays it's like 60 to
70% of it is just NTR garbage.
- [Garnt and Joey] Yeah.
- It's like, I can't nut to this.
Who's nutting to this?
- The majority of Japan is
nutting to it, apparently.
- All I wanna fucking see is two people
who know they shouldn't be
together, but just, you know,
for like one fucking.
- Cheeky little rule break.
- Having like a cheeky Nando's,
you know, have a cheeky little
blow job here and there,
you know, fucking have one or
two hot nights and then just.
- Mom doesn't need to know.
- And then just call it a day.
Unfortunately, hentai takes this as
"Let's rip someone's life
into pieces while we do this."
- That's what I wasn't
fond of with this one.
They were like, "I'm just gonna tell Mom."
That part really fucked me up.
I was like, "Why would you do that?"
- The part that made least
sense to me was just like,
Kirino is just like,
"I've left now, I fixed their marriage."
I'm just like, "In what way have you fixed
their fucking marriage?"
(all laughing)
- The matchmaker.
- I fixed their marriage by literally
getting my brother to fuck
me all over his house.
Every part of his house.
- We've had like a threesome
where we're just not gonna be
able to talk about for years.
I'm not gonna be able to look at my wife
in the eyes for like years to come, Jesus.
Imagine if we have kids,
like what the fuck?
- I love how after that like,
fucking intense threesome
scene and like Kirino leaves,
there's just like this monologue
of Kyousuke being like,
"Manami and I talked it out,
we're mending our wounds."
I'm like,
(Garnt laughing)
"Oh it's that easy, is it?"
Shit, all right, cool.
- It just be like that.
- It just be like, we just
talked it out, you know.
- It's like, "Babe, I know, I
kind of just fucked my sister
and fucked you at the same time,
but I think, I think we can
work through this right?"
- Happy wife, happy life, right?
(both laughing)
- She's like, "Yeah I'm glad.
This is like never
happened before, right?"
Uh......
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
"Looney Toons" ending.
(Connor hums)
- "This is just a phase, right?"
Yeah, it's just a phase, yeah, totally.
- She's like, "This just
happened one time, right?"
(all laughing)
The DNA test results have come in.
- 'Cause like, when you
see cheating in hentai,
normally it's like the
person who's cheating
against this fucking faceless dude
that you don't see, right?
It's like a face.
- I'm not a fan of it,
the character having
an active part in the
story, you know what I mean?
- I mean, that's the
difference between cheating
and NTR, you know?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And like even fucking Kirino's
husband comes back at this,
even though he's like a
faceless fucking guy, and just
- [Both] beats the shit out of Kyousuke.
- Like where did that come from?
- I love that.
- And he was just like.
- I love the ending scene too,
because he gets absolutely
the shit kicked out of him
and Kyousuke's just like, "worth it."
(both laughing)
- He's like, "I'm still
protecting Kirino."
I'm just like, "What is going on here?"
- How did you think that that would go?
How did you know that would go?
- But yeah, the reason this
is one of my favorite series,
like parody doujins of all time
is 'cause of the first two chapters.
The first two chapters, 10 out 10 hot.
- Hot as fuck
- That is my exact taste.
- I'm not gonna lie, one thing
that really did put me off,
I did make a note of this.
Why is she being like,
"he get me pregnant?"
but then be like, "Oh no."
(Joey laughing)
That was really fucking weird.
Can we admit that that's kind of weird?
Cheating with your stepbrother
is really pushing it
in what I can accept to be
like "Oh hehe, it's hot."
But then being like, she's
like, "Make me pregnant."
Literally the first time
she meets and I'm like,
"What am I supposed to think?"
What am I supposed to
think hearing this shit?
Am I supposed to be like,
yeah that's hot, dude.
Impregnate your sister, that'll show them.
That'll show everyone.
- I think this is, you saying this now,
I think this just shows that
I've just been so desensitized.
- You've literally just like.
(overlapping chatter)
- 'Cause I feel like
that's just the fucking,
that's just the default in
a lot of hentai, all right?
There's always one panel in every hentai
where it's just like, "make me pregnant,"
or "I'm going to become pregnant."
- I am trying to be supportive
of my friend's taste here
and I'm reading this, you know
and I wanna be like good
for Garnt, you know?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But then like, it's literally, again,
the amount of times I'm gonna reference
the fucking headset meme
where he rips it off.
I'm trying to get into this
and she's like, "make me pregnant,"
I'm like, "Fuck, fuck. Why, why?
What do you mean?"
- I think it's just because
sometimes your taste
or like my taste is like so specific
that it's kinda like,
I'm willing to look over
some of like the weirder
shit or the weirder aspects
of some hentai if there's
like this aspect that has done
like ridiculously,
ridiculously, well, you know?
- You sound like someone
who's like desperately digging
for good hentai after you've had it all.
You're like, "I'm missing something."
- I need to feel something.
- I'll forgive, I'll forgive
the weird fucking shit
just for a crumb of good blowjob art.
- If it scratches that one tiny itch,
that's all I need, that's all I need.
- This was fucking weird.
I did give this one to three out of 10.
- Three?
- Three.
- Honestly, there was very
few moments where I was like,
this is hot and there's so
many moments where I'm like,
"Fucking hell, fuck."
Like, I don't even smoke
and I wanted a smoke break
after this.
- This is a doujin to
read and you're like,
"I need a fucking smoke right now."
- I don't even smoke and I was like,
"Fuck, I need a cigarette."
Just like, fucking look out my window
and just be like, "Fuck."
- The thousand yard stare.
- But I feel like that's, to me,
that's what makes a great doujin.
Like if it can fucking
affect you in some way,
then that means at least-
- If it changes your life.
- At least it's doing
something right, right?
It's making you feel something, right?
- Yeah, of course.
(all laughing)
- My dick's so numb,
I'm just waiting for something to happen.
It doesn't matter what, disgust, anything,
I'll make it work, like anything.
- My dick is numb but my heart aches.
(Joey laughs)
- Three out of 10.
What are you gonna give this one, Joey?
- I don't know, I
weirdly enjoyed this one.
- Yes, fuck yes.
Oh my god.
- This is why we need a me on this podcast
to balance out the fucking
degeneracy we have over here.
- This is how I know Joey is a brother.
- I weirdly enjoyed this.
I give this that's probably
seven or an eight, yeah.
- Goddamn it.
- Yeah.
- Story's spicy, man.
It's a spicy ass story.
- I don't know, this is not spice.
Literally, the word
spice went out the window
when he told her fucking mom.
That was when I was like,
"This is not spicy."
- That's like the last fucking panel.
You should've already nutted by then.
You don't give a shit about.
- I don't wanna-
- He told his mom.
(both laughing)
- I don't wanna get post nut clarity
and then also find out
afterwards he told the mom
and it's like the biggest
whiplash of post nut clarity.
You'd be like, "Oh God, oh, Jesus."
- That's not spice.
That's like a Carolina Reaper to the eye.
- Oh God, Garnt what would you
rate this one out of 10 then
for you personally?
- Nine.
- Oh my God.
- The good parts were so
good that I'm just like,
to me, it's the most like
the most unique, dope,
like parody doujin I've read so far
in terms of building on
a premise and being able
to like take this premise in an anime
and just make a hot situation out of this.
- The dildo burn did it for me.
Like that was hilarious.
- Yeah, yeah.
- That was fucking hilarious.
- I respectfully disagree.
- All right.
- Moving on.
- The next one was "Pisu Hame."
What does that mean in
Japanese, "Pisu Hame?"
- Hame means to fuck and Pisu is peace.
- Peace fuck?
- Peace fuck.
- Fair enough.
- Yeah.
- So the premise of this
one was a strange one.
There was like, I guess.
- Whose do you think it is, first of all?
- Yours.
- Yeah.
- I thought it was yours.
This seemed very much like a you thing.
- Yeah.
- But I also really, really
liked the plot to this one.
I really enjoyed the plot.
- I love this plot.
- Yeah, that's a very good plot.
- The plot was good.
- Okay, first of all, I did read,
I was very, very confused because it came
with like a prequel.
- Yeah, that's like the
YouTube hook, right?
- Oh, yeah.
- Where you have like a few
pages to hook in the reader.
- Where it was just like a bunch of girls
who had been taking
photos of who were naked.
And I was very confused.
And then when I started reading it,
I almost forgot for a second
that I was reading a doujin
'cause I thought I was about
to get some kind of sick,
fucking epic doujin about Kendo.
- Kendo.
- Kendo fighting.
It very quickly became not that.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah yeah.
- Just for a second, I totally forgot
that I was reading porn and that I was-
- Just was like a regular manga?
- I totally escaped into a regular manga.
You have this little, the
chad woman who is this amazing
Kendo player, very
attractive, very beautiful.
And like the simp guy,
who's like this very tiny,
very wimpy looking character.
And then for some reason
during the story, she's like,
"Oh please, can you
help me with something?"
And obviously the wimpy character's like,
"Yes, of course I'll help you."
So they go to the office
and there's the guy
who's in charge of the Kendo club
who's engaged to the hot girl.
- To the girl, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Is he a student?
I don't know if that's clear.
- Yeah, he's a student.
- But he's literally built
like a motherfucking whale
on steroids, like this man is absolute.
- He's like nine feet tall.
- That's generous, he's
like 15 feet tall, muscular.
And he's like, "This is my fiancee.
By the way, I need you to
take photos of all the women
at the school."
- All the graduates, right?
- All the graduates, naked,
lewd, being fucked, anything.
And then there's just
so many quotes in this
are just very funny to me 'cause,
and then he's like, "Oh, is that a..."
The little wimpy character's like,
"Oh, is it okay that we take
sexual photos of the girls?"
He's like, "Oh yes, all
the girls have given
their consent to this."
(both laughing)
Literally the X to doubt, X to doubt.
Really?
- Yeah, because of the
long standing tradition
in the school, right?
- It's a long standing tradition,
not like this is like
some YouTuber cancel bait.
How is this-
- This is a tweet longer
waiting to blow up, man.
- How does this become a long set?
I wanna know that
backstory. Who started this?
How did it everyone just come-?
- This is like CW grooming.
- How did everyone give consent?
I feel like this needs
to be like a signed form
or something like that.
- I agree with that, I
really want to know more
of the story.
There must be an iron
clad contract to this.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Release waivers out the ass.
- You sign by blood.
- Yeah.
- There were so many funny-
"They have given their okay to
this," that's what they say.
- What I appreciate about this doujin
is that I always appreciate
a doujin when it takes
more than 20 pages to get
to the fucking, right?
- I appreciate that a lot about this.
I literally experienced two
hours of just the worst shit.
I've read the Oreimo one before this,
I was begging for something
that wasn't fucking awful.
So this was a breath of fresh air.
- 'Cause the difference
between a parody doujin
and an actual doujin
is that parody doujins,
if you're a fan of the show
- [Connor] You skip the plot.
- or the series, you can skip the context
'cause you know the context,
you can build on top of that.
But like the real challenge
with just a plain doujin
is that-
- Original stuff.
- Original you know, original
tankoban or whatever,
is that they need to
build up your investment
into the story by itself
with no pre-investment
to any franchise or whatever.
And normally that takes a long time,
and I can appreciate it.
It went like 40 pages,
it went like a whole chapter, I think.
- Almost, yeah.
- With no fucking
and I'm just like
(Garnt clapping)
respect, respect.
- Restraint, I appreciate it.
- [Joey] Exactly.
- One thing I really liked
about this one is that like
the whole, I guess point is that like,
obviously he's gonna fuck the main girl,
but they hold off on
it for so goddamn long.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I appreciate that.
- Wait, so did you read this whole thing?
- No, I read about nearly two stories.
- Two chapters.
- Yeah, there's the first
chapter was like 150 pages.
- No, it wasn't.
- It was like six parts to this.
- If you're thinking of the 500 page one,
those are 16 chapters put together.
- Oh, when I looked in the
websites, it's six stories
or whatever.
- [Garnt] Oh, okay.
- So, I mean, I read up until like-
- How many pages?
- Which girl did you get to?
Which one was the last one?
- I think he actually fucked the girl.
- Okay, you got further than me then.
- Which is like, I think
it's like 200 pages in,
but then there's still
like 400 more after that,
which I had didn't understand.
But I was still like, all
right, this story is pretty hot
because the whole premise
is that he has to then go
and he's recruited this.
- He's doing his job.
- Yeah.
- This wimpy kid is recruited
to take all the naked
and lewd photos, you know,
and if he has to help
to get the photos done, he does.
So he just starts fucking everyone.
(Garnt laughing)
- As you do.
- I appreciate the hustle, you know?
I was like, "You know what, good for him."
'Cause this is, you're not.
- He was scared at first,
but then he gets more and more confident.
- You know, ticked all the boxes.
It was like consensual, attractive,
kid coming into his own.
Getting pussy.
(Joey laughing)
Good for him.
I was rooting for him.
- It's a coming of age story.
- Yeah and you know, I
thought it was very attractive
that she was watching the whole time,
giving moral support.
Who doesn't want that?
- I love the scene where
she just like comes around,
grabs his dick, and is
like, "You've got this."
- It's like IRL Twitch chat
with fucking, you know?
Its like Pog, go in!
Pog, take the photo!
(Connor exclaims in Japanese)
You know, just good fun.
I don't know, this was just good.
- I'm surprised you liked this one.
- I'm surprised you like this one as well.
- Really?
- Well yeah.
- This didn't seem,
okay because this one-
- I like the long game.
I liked that they were
reserved with a lot of things.
- 'Cause this one is one
of my favorites doujins
of all time.
- Yeah.
- The art style threw me
off a little bit and stuff.
- It's unique, isn't it?
- But then I got into it.
I was like, "You know what, I
fuck with it. I fuck with it."
- That's exactly how I felt.
- And then, you know, because
obviously you can't just have
the gimmick of, he goes to
take picture, he fucks them.
'Cause that would get old.
So then they started introducing
like these fucking battles.
- Yeah, that's what I liked as well.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- When I'm just like-
- I was like, "This is
so fucking dope that
I'm here for it."
- The betting battles right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So they would bet on something.
So the first bet is that he
has to choose what he thinks
is her favorite volumes
of her like lewd outfits.
Am I correct?
- Yeah, yeah.
So she's like a gravure model
who does like sexual stuff.
And she's like, pick two
things that I consider
my best works and he's like, easy game.
- And then if you pick
them, I'll fuck you.
- I was already a super-fan anyway.
- And he's like, "If
you lose, you throw out
all of your porn. If you
win, you get to fuck me."
- And he gets to fuck
her, so congratulations.
And then there's-
- Spoiler alert.
- There's another one where
they did like wishbone breaking.
- Oh yeah, yeah, with the grass.
That's like a really old Japanese game.
- Yeah and then he wins this
20 foot Kendo man is like,
"He's so powerful, he's
won two betting games.
This kid's good."
And it's like.
- It's like, "We need more photos."
- He literally guessed doujins
and then played wishbone,
a luck game, what do you-
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And it's just like,
"He might get all the photos this year,"
implying that some of them
don't want their photos taken,
which is like, I was like,
"Oh, that's a little weird
but I'll forgive it."
But it was-
- [Joey] Go, go, go.
Some of the later chapters,
it does become like that.
- Yeah.
- I thought, you know what, fair enough.
I see the vision, I
appreciate the execution.
All around, good fun for the family.
- [Garnt] What I love about-
- Cheers.
- Yeah, cheers.
(all laughing)
Cheers to that.
- Cheers to that.
- Cheers to consensual for
the most part, I think.
I didn't get far enough.
- I'm sad you didn't make
it to like pretty much
like the finale or like the ending plot.
The ending, because there's like a whole,
there's like three chapters.
- Sell me on it.
- There's three chapters
where the wimpy kid,
the main character fights
the student council
brick shit house in a wrestling match.
- Oh, okay.
- I mean, I knew that they
were building up to it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's very obvious that that was gonna be
the final showdown.
- And while that's
happening, all of the girls
that he's fucked are
getting like gang banged
by the entire school.
And he's like, "If you wanna stop this,
beat me in a wrestling match."
And I was just like, "what?"
- You know like after reading
all of Joey's recommendations,
I like figured out Joey's tastes.
He recommends a doujin.
If there's a panel on it
with more than like
eight tits in one panel,
that's a Joey.
- [Connor] True.
- That's a Joey doujin.
- Yeah, yeah you're right.
- I'm mad that you're right.
(both laughing)
- The more the merrier.
- But like what I love about
a story in a doujin like this
is when like, they introduced
the one winning girl
at the beginning show.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I mean she was the hottest.
- Oh, 100%, she's the hottest.
- I don't know how like doujin
artists, they just know.
They know I'm gonna make
this girl the hottest.
- There's something
about a supporting girl
that you can't help but root for.
You're like, she is just helping,
she's just doing her part.
Fuck it, literally.
- And it's like they
must have like a talent
to be able to like, make
a girl that you know
is like just radiates
best girl energy, right?
Like they just radiate best girl energy
and everyone just unanimously
agrees that this is best girl.
And every girl is just
like the losing girl.
- Honestly, Shiwasu No
Okina who's the artist,
he's like fucking amazing at that
'cause all of these other ones,
he always introduces this
like, beginning girl.
- Yeah.
- And whether she gets
fucked in the beginning
or right at the end, she always ends up
being the best girl.
- Because throwback to the hentai episode,
the one thing that I did
like about that one thing
that you picked, even though
I didn't particularly-
- Which one?
- The one that was like
the Eto era Japanese.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I was like-
- That's the one.
- I least liked the fact
that they took three episodes
to build that shit up before
they fucked, you know?
I like it when they tease you.
'Cause you know, you can
go on fucking Pornhub
and you can skip two minutes in,
you're already at the fucking meat of it.
I like it when they make
you wait for it sometimes.
It's like you making me
feel like these characters
are worth it, you know what I mean?
'Cause when they immediately
put that pants down
and he's fucking two other women,
I'm like, "I'm not
invested. You've lost me.
It's a no from me."
- I like being able to wait to
see the best girl, you know.
- I'm impatient, but I'm patient.
- I'm also impatient.
Sometimes I'm just like, "Let's
just skip to episode five
and let's just see, okay."
But like, I feel like
the best times is like,
when you know there's a
reason to turn the next page.
There's a reason to like
watch the next episode.
Like, it's like "Metal Gear Solid,"
the best is yet to come.
- I don't consider the plumber
turning up a riveting story
worth me turning the fucking page.
- Oh, I'm invested in
what part of the house
is he gonna fix?
- Oh shit, is it there?
Which kind of clog is it?
I'm fucking hyped to
see which kind of clog.
Is it a grease?
- I wanna see all the
size wrenches he has.
- Is it a grease clog
or a toilet paper clog?
Can't wait, you know?
I mean, I think that's the
one thing that at least
I can appreciate about the doujin,
is that you can kind of almost,
if there's a story, you can
kind of read it in your own pace
and you can get the feel
for it that you want.
I can respect that.
I wish that I could read it
and then the moment the fucking starts,
I'm like turn on the hentai version.
- Well, this one actually
does have a hentai version.
- Yeah, I was about to
say this one does have
an hentai adaptation.
- You say that, is it bad?
It sounds bad.
- It's Queen Bee.
- Oh, I'm gonna watch it.
- All right, I'm actually
curious about your opinion.
(Connor speaking indistinctly)
I'm actually curious about your opinion
now that you're gonna
go from like a doujin
to an adaptation of that
doujin that you enjoyed.
- Because there's another
one by Shiwasu No Okina
that I was debating on
whether to recommend
called Nudist Beach, which is-
- I love the Nudist Beach,
the hentai, it's great.
- Yeah, yeah, that's the same guy.
- Yeah, I like that one.
- And doujin version is
like one of my favorites
and also Cahu's favorite.
And we like bonded over that.
But like I was like, "Do I recommend it?"
But like Pisu Hame just has a better story
in my opinion.
- I like that story a lot.
- [Joey] Yeah, I know you love stories.
- With Nudist Beach, when
I watched that originally,
I was like, "You know what?"
You know when you watch
something and you just know
this is popular.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I'm just watching, I'm
like, I know this one.
I don't know anything about
hentai or doujin community
and what the fuck they get up to.
But I watched that and I'm like,
"I bet this is famous as fuck."
Just from watching this I'm
like, "This shit is too good."
- Who adapted Nudist Beach again?
- Queen Bee.
- No, it wasn't, it was
good adaption though.
- Was it?
I thought it was Queen Bee.
- No, I swear, I watched
that and it was good.
- I don't think it was Queen Bee.
- Really?
- I swear it was a good
adaptation, I swear it was.
- [Joey] Let's see. Let's see.
- But I gave this one.
What did I give this one?
I gave this one a nine out of 10.
- [Joey] Really?
- Genuinely, I dig the story.
- Honestly, that's really surprised me,
I thought you would hate this one.
- Cheers to that.
- Cheers, cheers to that.
- Look at us, look at us, look at us.
Recommending each other porn.
- We are two for four, I think.
- Two for four.
- Two for four right now.
- We're slowly converting him.
We're slowly converting him.
- Oh, I'm not gonna say I'm
gonna go home and read this shit
or it's my preferred.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah, of course.
- But if you're gonna
sit here and force me
to read this shit, I'll sit.
- Okay, here's a question then.
Like if you had just experienced
this through the hentai,
would you have watched through the story?
- Yeah, for sure, for sure.
- [Garnt] Really?
- I mean, most hentai,
I watch their story.
- [Garnt] Really?
- 'Cause it's like 19
minutes, it's not a big ask.
- That's the most
un-Connor thing I've heard
in the history of this podcast.
- Okay, do you know when you,
I don't know if you do this, right?
Okay, I gotta ask.
When you're doing your
business or something.
If you finish your business
and there's like six minutes
left, do you just save it
for another time, the rest six minutes,
or do you just keep watching
and see what else happens?
- Save it.
- I save it.
- Yeah, me too, me too.
(Garnt laughing)
- My man.
- I'm like, this was so good
that I don't wanna spoil the rest.
- Yeah!
- Goddamn Connor, I've
never connected to you
on such like a spiritual level before
until you just said that moment.
- It takes restraint, but
I'm like, "You know what, no.
I could skip ahead and find
the best part, but no."
- No, no, no, this is fresh
content for next time.
- Connor, I agree.
(all laughing)
- Holy shit, Garnt agrees with me.
'Cause you don't wanna spoil.
You get so limited.
You know, I've realized with
hentai, it is literally like,
you know, it's like mining
for diamonds in Minecraft,
you just don't get it.
- That's what I'm saying,
that's what I'm saying.
- You don't get the good shit.
- It's like when you find a good shit.
When you find one of the good shit,
you gotta save that shit, man.
- There's like 10 hentai
that I can probably,
I can be like, you know what,
these are probably my favorite
that I can revisit.
But like they never come around
'cause we have so much goddamn NTR.
It's fucking, it's awful.
And the moment we don't get
NTR, as much as you know,
I can work with Queen
Bee, but I don't like it
where every single non-NTR is Queen Bee.
- [Joey] Yeah, honestly.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- What is happening here, can
we not do this for 10 seconds?
- 'Cause just imagine me when I go onto
just like regular hentai website.
And I see Pisu Hame
episode one, I was like,
"My time has come. My favorite hentai
has finally been adapted."
- When did they come out,
when did they come out?
- The doujin or the hentai?
- The hentai.
- A couple years ago.
- Yeah, it was quite old.
- It's quite recent.
- I mean, I wonder I'm like,
is Japan just ahead on porn?
Like, are they speed running it?
It is this where all porn is gonna go to
where everyone in the
world is gonna be NTR fans?
- God, I don't know, I
really fucking hope not.
- 'Cause I feel like they're
like five stages ahead
of like fucked up shit
than the rest of the world.
- I mean it's because
of Japan just accepts
any kind of fucked up hentai, right?
- Is this where the
world is going towards?
Are we just all gonna be NTR fans?
Are we just all gonna
be NTR fans in 20 years?
- Here's the thing, there's
obviously someone out there
watching NTR.
- A lot of people.
- [All] A lot of people.
- I actually know someone.
- Sydney.
- Well, there you go, point taken.
- You see the thing is that it is like.
- You literally just
proved your own point.
- NTR sometimes is attractive.
You know, I will admit
there are one or two
where I'm like, you know what, they had me
in the first half.
- Yeah, it's not all bad.
- Which ones?
- But, I can't off the top of my head.
There've been one or two
where I'm like, you know what,
"This is good" but then
I'm like, "Ah, it's NTR.
Not gonna do it, not gonna do it."
Because I'm like, you know
what, like does vanilla
really have to die?
'Cause I feel like vanilla
is the minority of hentai that we get now.
It's very rare where you just get a,
they like each other, there's no cheating,
there's no sibling rivalry.
Oh my God, what?
- I think it's because in the context
- I do that.
- of Japanese.
(all laughing)
- I think it's because in the
context of Japanese audiences
to read it, it's like,
"Why would I read this
when I could just have it myself?"
- 'X' to doubt on that one.
- But like with your
vanilla thing, do you count,
for example, step siblings
or step parents, step mother,
whatever if there's no other
complications other than them,
for some reason just being
step siblings or stepmother.
Is that vanilla to you?
- I'd say yeah, probably.
- [Garnt] Yeah, I mean-
- That's pretty vanilla,
I mean that's probably the most vanilla
you can get nowadays.
- Yeah, I mean-
- Or like childhood friend
or something, right?
- 'Cause the thing is, it's
it makes it even rarer, right?
- I mean, literally, you
go on any porn website now,
but is literally all step-mom everything.
Everything is step.
- [Joey] Really?
- Yes.
- Are you sure, or is that
just the shit you look up?
- No, no, no, I kid you
not, you go on this shit
and all the most viewed
shit, it's all step mom.
And I'm like, "What is happening?"
(overlapping chatter)
I'm here for it, but like
when did this happen?
- I don't know when it happened, right?
- You know, right?
You see it too.
- Meilyne, can you search up some
of the most searched terms on Pornhub?
Like, 'cause I guarantee,
I think step-mom's.
(Meilyne speaks indistinctly)
(all laughing)
Okay, Ashley, Ashley, Ashley, you do it.
- Yeah, Ashley do it.
Like I think it's either
top three or top five,
because step-mom is up there.
- What happened?
Because I swear like five, six years ago,
lesbian porn was always number one.
- [Joey] Yes.
- It was never dethroned,
and then all of a sudden
out of nowhere in like
the space of two years,
all the fucked up shit goes to the top.
What happened in those two?
Is this coronavirus where people are like,
"I guess NTR is pretty good, huh?"
- I'm looking up the most
popular tags for doujins
right now and would you believe that milf
is in the top 20?
- I mean, I hope so, I hope so.
- But do you know what's
directly on top of that?
- What?
- Incest.
(Joey laughing)
- It's concerning.
No, this is not a celebratory moment.
- I will take my crown right now.
- No, no, no, no, no.
- Oh, but then you know what?
- Fellow degenerates rise up.
Degenerates rise up.
- Man, there are some like,
oh my God, number 10 is shotacon.
- Ashley, you're literally
looking on Pornhub?
Just search top.
(all laughing)
- Oh my God.
- Just search top
Pornhub searches.
- You don't gotta open up
Pornhub.
- Your boss is sitting
right next to you and you're on Pornhub.
(Garnt laughing)
- [Ashley] For the record,
she told me to do it.
(all laughing)
- Meilyne, Meilyne what are you doing?
Stop corrupting Ashley like this.
- [Meilyne] Wait, what if
the most searched terms
are like in the top-
- It's literally, they do a survey.
- Yeah, they do a survey.
- They do a survey.
- They literally do a survey and like a-
- Speaking of shotacon, should
we get onto the next one?
- Yeah, sure, let's go on to the next one.
- Seikatsu Shuukan.
- Wait, wait, wait.
- [Ashley] Do you wanna know that 2019,
number one was amateur,
number two was alien.
- Those were the search terms.
Search terms, search terms.
There, there. That's
what you're going for.
- [Ashley] Search terms, Japanese.
- Hey!
- Japanese number one?
- [Ashley] Number two is
hentai, number three is lesbian.
Number four is milf.
- Hentai is above lesbian now?
- What?
What's number five?
- That's like, although-
- [Ashley] Number five is...
- [Meilyne] Milf.
- [Ashley] Korean.
- [Meilyne] Oh, it's Korean.
- I swear it's like nearly
like, you go on these websites,
it is like Russia driving
half of this shit.
- Where's stepmom?
- [Ashley] Seven.
- Okay.
- Stepmom and milf though.
Stepmom and milf are
normally very like closely.
But also if you look at it,
the amount of people in Russia
that watch hentai is insane.
- [Joey] Really?
- [Connor] Hentai is massive
in Russia, it's insane.
- Fuck, I need to move to Russia.
- Putin's like put "Mother Knows
Best" on my 90 inch OLED TV
(all laughing)
while I jerk off on my
Italian leather couch.
- Or my polar bear rug.
(all laughing)
- So yeah, the next one
is "Seikatsu Shuukan."
I'm near certain Garnt
recommended this one.
- It was me.
(Joey laughing)
- Are you?
I'm not gonna lie, I'ma
say it right now, boys.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I liked the hentai version to this one.
- Yeah, the hentai version
is fucking ridiculous, yeah.
- Because, dude, you
can't, the animation alone.
If you-
- God tier.
- [Connor] In the hentai version of this
it is so goddamn good.
- [Joey] God tier.
- And I was so confused
when I opened this doujin
'cause I was like, what is
this story in the start?
This is the shit story.
Get to the story I know.
- [Joey] Yeah, the good one.
- The good story.
'Cause the first story is just like.
- So, this is like a
collection of stories.
- Is it two stories?
- It's like two or three stories in there.
- Okay, so there's two stories in this.
It's "Seikatsu Shuukan" and I think it's,
so the first part is like a teacher
who fucks their student
story and like this teacher
is not very charismatic,
very creepy, very rapey,
really weird.
You know, you get interested this girl
and she's a little concerned, you know?
She's like, "Why are all
the guys looking at my big,
you know, big-"
- Big badonkas.
- Badonkas.
- And this teacher's like,
"Oh, don't worry about it.
I'll help you, I'll help
you get used to them
because if you don't
care about it anymore,
no one's gonna look at them" and I'm like.
- Genius logic.
- I'm like, "Ah, okay."
And so he's like, "Oh yeah,
just take your bra off
in front of me so you can get more used
to showing them off."
And I'm like, "Oh God, all
right, it's one of these."
'Cause it's just like,
it's really rapey and like,
'cause you did recommend,
the next one we'll talk about is Tujuan.
I think that's done much more tastefully
than this Wan Shou.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Not a fan of this Wan Shou at all.
- Yeah, the Wan Shou I didn't
really want you to care about.
- But the Wan Shou was like
a 100 pages long though.
- It was long, because it's like,
and this is the thing
that I hate about hentai
but this happens all the goddamn time.
Let me see it.
So one trope that I really
am not fond of in hentai
is where the girl is like,
"No, oh my God, please don't."
And they're clearly being
sexually assaulted really.
- [Joey And Garnt] Yeah.
- And then suddenly, they start
doing it and they're like,
"Oh wait, I like this now."
And I'm like, "I don't
think that's how it works."
(Joey laughing)
Why haven't you bought GamerSupps yet?
What is going on?
- Did you not know that this episode
was sponsored by GamerSupps?
- We've said it three times now
and you haven't bought GamerSupps yet.
- The coupon code is
TRASHTASTE, what are you doing?
- We're not wearing
the shirts for nothing.
- Fool me once, shame on me.
Fool me twice, shame on you.
Fool me three times, I don't
even know who to blame anymore.
- What's going on?
Did we not convinced you enough?
- Are we not gamer enough for you?
- Have you not tried their
newest flavor, Waifu candy?
It's delicious, what's
wrong with you guys?
- I mean, come on, look at these Waifus.
Look at all these beautiful Waifus
that you can choose from to
get your gamer juice from.
Come on gamers!
- [Meilyne] And they have free samples.
- They have free samples.
(all laughing)
- Thanks Meilyne.
- Thank you.
- Guys, I know you haven't
clicked the link yet
and that's fine, it's fine.
No, I'm not angry, I'm not angry
but maybe this will entice you.
Joey, tell them what it is.
- Okay.
(all laughing)
Did you know the first 5,000
people to click the link,
add the samples to their cart,
and checkout with code "Free"
will get free samples
delivered to them, no bullshit.
- That is the last chance.
This is your last chance,
I'm telling you, now.
- What am I, your mom?
Go buy GamerSupps.
- Your mum would love these cups.
They're great.
- I'm not angry,
I'm just disappointed if you
don't click the link right now.
- Click the link in
description down below.
- Back to the episode.
- Generally, did not
enjoy this teacher fellow.
I thought he was a little bit rapey.
- Little unpleasant.
- And like I said in the hentai episode,
not really fond of that kind of stuff.
To me, it's just like, "Aah, oh, okay."
And he's like, "Oh, I'm gonna teach you
how to be more comfortable
with your boobs."
I'm like, "Are you really?
Are you sure about that?"
- Did you say like the name of the doujin,
'cause I'll tell you
the name of the doujin
is "Abstinence Club," at least
the first story arc, right?
Which is, it's obviously
nothing about abstinence.
(Joey laughs)
I'm sorry.
- There's no abstinence to be found here.
- It's quite the opposite.
- These are not good Christian girls,
that's not what we're talking about here.
- And there's two things that personally,
I'm not really fond of or
I'm like, "Oh, whatever"
that come up in this doujin.
First one being that apparently
dick can just convert
your feelings entirely
and that you can just
suddenly love it once it's inside of you.
I'm like, "Pretty sure that's
not how it works, whatever."
- It's gotta be pretty fucking
good dick for you to do that.
- You'd be surprised about how many times
that crops up in hentai.
- It's literally every
single fucking hentai.
- I know, where it's just
like, "Aha, you don't want it?
Well, you obviously haven't
had the giga-chad dick yet,
let me introduce you."
- Say that after you feel my dick.
- It's so fucking dumb, I hate it so much.
And then also they have
that whole fucking trope of,
for some reason, this happens
a lot in hentai as well
where the girl is having
sex with the teacher
because of course she is.
And outside, there's
another student who happens
to catch wind of this going on.
And naturally, instead of
being like, "Oh God, oh my God"
and running away and telling friends,
she's like, "I think I
should start nutting.
I think I should start
masturbating right now.
Right now outside."
- It's the optimal time to nut.
- Either winter or summer in Japan,
which are both wildly
uncomfortable seasons
to be doing this outside, by the way.
So this is just a terrible
experience overall
and I did not enjoy
this first story at all,
I thought was shit.
And I was really confused, I was like,
"Man, I really liked the
anime version of this,
I thought it was really hot."
- I didn't even remember that
this had an anime adaptation
'cause like I had to like-
- You'd remember if you'd seen it.
- No, no, no, exactly 'cause I was like,
"This name kind of rings a bell."
- Yeah, same, same, same.
- So I look at the anime and
than I look at the doujin
and I'm just like, "These
aren't the same fucking story."
- Hold up a minute.
- I literally thought
I had made a mistake,
and I'm like, I was just like-
- They adapted the better
half into an anime.
- Smart man, smart man.
- [Garnt] Thankfully. Thankfully.
- 'Cause the first half is
every other fucking doujin
that exists and every hentai.
It's like, "All right,
whatever, the fucking teacher
abused his power, yada, yada,
yada, whatever. Whatever."
- [Joey] Whatever.
- We'll get to it.
- Okay, let's let's get to
the part you wanna talk about.
- Okay, you know-
- Let's get to the good part.
- The anime adaptation
of this one, I have seen.
I enjoy it thoroughly. I think it's great.
The animation, very good.
Because the boy isn't actually a shotacon
makes it in my head, I'm like, free pass.
I'm like it's free real estate
because he transforms
temporarily, so it's-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I'm willing to bend the rules.
- This is like if I
close my eyes and forget
it's Connor's voice
coming out, I'm just like,
"Man, is Joey fucking talking right now?
What is going on?"
(all laughing)
- That's like a me argument.
- Are you okay with shotacons, Connor?
Is that what you're saying?
- No, I have watched, I don't
know what the other famous one
is that always comes up
with like the big, big milfs
and the tiny, tiny kids that I do not.
- The Yokai one?
- I fucking hate that one.
That one is fucking disgusting.
And I accidentally watched it
and I thought, "Oh God, oh!"
You know what I'm on about,
if you've seen it, it's
this vile shotacon.
- It's like the eight foot milf right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's fucking disgusting.
- It's like fucking
watching "Attack on Titan,"
you know what I mean?
- It's like, POV: the fucking
colossal titan fucks you.
It's like, I don't wanna
watch this, I don't want this.
- I was just like, this
doujin disappointed me
so fucking much, all right?
And the hentai also disappoints me
'cause you know why?
Do you know what the worst,
you know the only thing
worse thing than a loli?
A shotacon.
(Connor and Joey laughing)
- I agree though. I agree.
- Because the thing, with loli-
- They're equal in my hate.
- 'Cause like, no, no,
they're not equal to me
'cause with loli hentai, I was like,
"I was never gonna jack off
to you anyway. It's whatever.
I can just skip over this."
The one reason why it's so fucking hard
to find milf hentai is because
90% of them are shotacon.
And the thing is, most of them
have like the fucking hottest
milf, like perfectly crafted
milf from God, right?
- Perfectly crafted milf.
(all laughing)
- I don't think there's that many.
I think you're over
exaggerating a little bit.
- That's what it feels like to me.
- That's a fair few, yeah.
- And I'm just like, "All right,
I'm in this, I'm invested.
I'm ready for this hentai."
And then the fucking shota
comes out and I'm just like,
"You were this close to
greatness, we had it!
And then you lost it!"
- They had us in the first half.
(both laughing)
- You know, I can
understand the frustration.
But I think this is an exception.
(all laughing)
- Hell yeah.
- You know, if I had read
the doujin and thought,
"So what, so what?"
Another like B-tier.
But you watch the anime
version, you're like,
"This has a place."
- S-tier.
(Joey laughing)
- I'm like, "Okay, now we're
talking, now we're talking."
- This is such a one, like,
this is such a Shyamalan twist
for me 'cause I thought you
were gonna hate this one.
- Now, how can I-
- I thought you were gonna hate this one.
- How?
When you watch the animation
of this one, how can-
- Because it has a loli and a shota in it.
- Okay, the loli one, I
thought it was, I don't know.
I really liked the redhead girl.
- Yeah, the redhead girl's hot.
- Red headed girl.
- I was just like, red
headed girl is fucking hot.
- Yeah.
- Shota, why, why?
- I think-
- It's like if you have
the fucking Mona Lisa
and you just decide to
fucking piss on it, you know?
- Do you ever see something
that happens in porn
that it like hits something
where you're like,
"Oh, I didn't know I was into
that, but that's very nice."
- Yeah, that's what I
like, search for everyday.
(Garnt laughing)
- Try to fill that craving every day.
- There was a scene in it
where she like gives a hand job
at the dinner table and I'm like,
I don't know why that was very
attractive, but I was like,
oh, I'm into that.
- The redhead girl.
- I'm into that.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I'm like, "You've
sold me, I wanna invest.
How do I invest in this?
Put my money in the stocks."
- Stonks.
- Put my money in this stock.
- To the moon.
(all laughing)
- Like that kind of shit,
I'm like, "I'm here for it."
But like, I know it's
terrible, just like my body.
My mind's telling me no, but my body,
it's like, literally that.
It's like, I know this is fucked
and I'm always very, very hard on you guys
for this kind of shit.
So I feel like it's very critical of me.
- Well, I mean, I'm
just happy we found out
that you have a new favorite fetish,
which is cheeky hand job under the table.
- Honestly, cheeky hand
job at the family table.
What's a better genre?
(all laughing)
I like danger in mine.
- You like a bit of spice, would you say?
- No, no, I like danger, not spice.
I don't want Garnt's spice.
I don't want Garnt's
spice anywhere near me.
- That's me, that's me.
- I like danger.
I like the fact that anyone could walk in,
I like that kind of shit.
- [Joey] Right, right, right.
- I like that kind of stuff.
- He likes having a danger
wank, that's what he does.
- Danger wank.
- I'm not out here in the
fucking, the taxi wanking.
I'm not saying that, but a
little bit of, not spice,
a little bit of danger, I didn't say it.
A little bit of danger adds
a little something to it.
- "Danger Wank" is gonna be my next album.
- But also every single, you know,
again, like my love for like
this thing is purely based
on the art.
It's not even a doujin
thing at this point.
The doujin was mid when I was reading it.
- Right, right, okay, so review it.
- 'Cause you are talking
about the animation, right?
- 'Cause the animation is so goddamn good.
Pink pineapple like, "finna
bring my A game to this one"
for some reason.
- I completely agree, watching
the animation of this,
the animation for hentai
standards is fucking godly.
- What happened?
I need to know what happened.
Why is this so good?
- This is also like a fuck,
I'm surprised that no one
recommended this on our
hentai episode, right?
'Cause it's just that famous.
- I was going to, but then
I thought he would hate it.
- No, I like this one, I like this one.
- Because I was like,
"I don't know if Connor's
into shota or not."
- No, I'm not, most of
it I absolutely despise.
This is probably the only one
where I'm like, "that's hot."
- [Joey] Really?
- Yeah, this is the only one
I've ever seen that I'm like,
"I think this is good."
- That's really surprising.
I'm learning a lot
about you today, Connor.
- What can I say?
I'm willing to bend my morals.
- All right, so just purely
just based on the doujin,
out of 10.
- Like a six, five.
- Six.
- It was like the first story
really ruined it for me.
The first story was so basic,
so bland, so insulting.
None of the characters were hot.
The teacher was fucking, just
not even remotely attractive.
I was not into the
teacher character at all.
And we'll get into the
next teacher character.
- What I'm getting out of this is like,
what if like fucking Ufotable animated
some loli hentai?
Would Connor enjoy it because
the animation's that good?
I don't know.
- Listen, in the other
episode, I was saying
I like my hentai animation
bad because sometimes
I feel like I should-
- Oh my God, you did.
I completely forgot about that.
- Because sometimes I feel
like it serves the story better
to have like bad
animation 'cause sometimes
the fucking isn't that great and I'm like,
"You know, that's fine."
- We are talking to the one
and only fan of Milky, right?
- But for this, this is
one of them where I'm like
the animation is so goddamn
good where it feels like
this is better than most anime
we've been getting recently,
So it's like, "What am I supposed to do?"
How can I hate on this?
This is just so goddamn good.
I'm not saying I want all
hentai to be like this
because God knows we'd get
50 NTRs animated like this.
And my mind can't take
that, that would be 50 NTRs.
- Unfortunately, the NTRs are like some
of the best animated.
- They are.
- Yeah, they are.
- They always are. I
fucking hate it, I hate it.
It's like they draw this ugly bastard
with the detail of a Mona Lisa.
And it's like, why would you do this?
What is wrong with you?
How is the staff okay doing this?
Like, I just don't get it, but it's fine.
- It's like they're just
playing nut chicken, right?
Because it's just like, are
you willing to nut to this?
Are you willing to nut to this animation?
- We can't always have a masterpiece.
I've accepted that not
everything can be a masterpiece.
You know, literally.
The animation, watch it, it's great.
But yeah, this is good,
I like the animation.
The story was kind of
shit, but the animation
very much saves the story.
- We just reviewed the hentai
not the doujin, by the way.
- Essentially, I mean, I genuinely,
when I got to the second hard, I'm like,
"seen it, skipped it."
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
I already know exactly what happens.
I went through to make sure.
It was like one for one the same as well.
So I was like whatever.
- Was there a reason why
you suggested this doujin?
- It's just the first one I
thought of when I thought like,
you know, all the girls are hot.
Like it's just an interesting premise.
Like, I don't know.
Again, this is another
one where it's like,
as long as you're okay
with the whole shota thing,
it's very inoffensive.
(all laughing)
- That's a very big ask.
- Just get over the shota, it's fine.
Just pretend you're the
shota, it's all right.
- I don't know, is it one
of those things, like,
is it 'cause I'm a guy
where I can forgive it
a little less, is that why?
- What'd you mean?
- Like with the shota in this case,
am I making an exception 'cause I'm a guy
and I could be like, you
know, he was an adult
in the start of this thing.
- Right, but if he was like a full on kid.
- If he was genuinely a kid,
I don't think I could enjoy.
- I mean this is like a
very deep conversation
that I don't feel we have time
to explore on this podcast.
- [Connor] We don't, no.
- Maybe at a later date.
- Maybe on a future podcast.
- This is definitely one of
those things where I'm like,
I hate letting the exception like,
I hate letting them be
like the Uno reverse card,
kind of save it, but
for this one, I'm like,
"Ah, it kind of does though for me."
Like he acts like an
adult, he is an adult.
All right, fuck it.
All right, I'll let it slide.
- Like the thing that
turns me off originally
was that he didn't know
that he wasn't a shota.
The girls didn't know that
he wasn't a shota either.
- I did think it was weird
when I first watched it
and they're just suddenly
into him now that he's a kid.
- Yeah, 'cause all the
girls are into shotas.
- And I'm like, there's a few
things we need to unpack here.
- Wait, wait, wait.
So it's kind of like when
you have the siblings fucking
but then they be like, but
they are step siblings.
- No, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, because there was-
- This video is under fair
use, I'm not under copyright.
- No, no, no because there was
no moment where she was like,
"I'm gonna ruin your life,
I'm gonna impregnate you."
"Impregnate me, ruin my marriage."
There was none of that.
That's pretty fucking hard to deal with,
I don't want marriages being ruined
while I'm trying to have a wank.
Like you know what I mean?
That's not what I wanna deal with.
Let's get on to the last one.
Oh, the second last one.
- All right, second last one.
- Which is "Kyoushi To Seito
To," "Teacher and Student."
- [Joey And Garnt] Yeah.
- So this one's obviously
Garnt's 'cause the last one's-
- This one's mine.
- You know what I had this
down as Garnt's, actually.
- [Joey] Okay, perfect.
- Which I, again, like, I'm shocked I got
some of these wrong 'cause I thought
I would get them all right.
- Yeah, I was shocked
you got them wrong too.
I thought it would've been fairly obvious.
- I thought it was fairly obvious.
- It was just because me
and Garnt had a conversation
the other day where Garnt
mentioned the word shota
and I'm like, "This has gotta be Garnt."
- He said the word.
- He literally said he word
shota to me like a week ago,
it must be Garnt.
(Garnt laughing)
He's trying to fucking inception my ass.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
Yeah, I mean this one was weird
because I thought the premise was really
quite attractive, you know?
I thought it was quite hot.
And then suddenly things
just started happening
where I'm like, "Ooh, ooh, I don't know,
I don't know about this."
- [Joey] Really?
- So, let me explain the premise.
So a teacher who works at
the school is broke, I guess.
- Very broke.
- Very broke and she has a job.
- Full time teaching which-
- Obviously isn't paying the dough.
- Seems like everyone
else is managing fine.
So her genius solution
is to ask one of the kids
whose dad owns an apartment complex.
- Yeah, he's a rich kid.
- To just stay in his house.
And so he says no, because
he's a very responsible
chad child and says no,
he says no to this woman.
No, you're my teacher, you can't stay
at my fucking apartment,
why the fuck would you?
So she turns up at his door, naturally.
- As you do.
- As you do when you've been rejected,
just fucking turn up at that door.
This is already extremely
wildly inappropriate
for HR standards and
should invite yourself in
and then she just starts living with him.
And mad props to the kid, pushes her away
and says no like 10 times.
That has to be rewarded.
Claps to you chad, king shit.
But it's a doujin, you
could only last so long.
But the fact that he
said no a bunch of times,
I respect that.
He's respecting the HR
standards of the workplace.
And frankly for a kid, very professional.
I noted "I'm calling HR. How
did this woman get this job?"
(both laughing)
That's what I did write down
because she's essentially
just trying to fuck this guy constantly,
and I'm just wondering like,
"How did she get this job?
What's going on here?
What's going on here?"
- She probably did a sneaky
hand job under the table.
- Did she try to fuck the guy?
From what I remember-
- No, no, no.
- She definitely did.
- Did she?
- Yeah, she literally grabbed his dick out
and started sucking it.
- Oh yeah, the was the first time around.
- No, that was the first time.
- That was the first time around.
- Before that, even before
she even came to his house,
she's like, "Do you wanna touch my boobs?
I'll let you do it if I
get to stay in your house."
And I'm like-
- No, but she said like jokingly, right?
'Cause she's like supposed
to be like ahaha, hehe.
- She's a fucking teacher,
she can't say that shit
jokingly to the student.
- It's a doujin bro.
- It's a doujin.
- Wait, can I have a beer, Ashley?
- Yeah, can you get me a beer as well?
- From the fridge, I need
a beer for this shit.
I can't talk about this.
Can't talk about this
shit without drinking.
Are you kidding?
We've run out of wine.
- All right, so to explain why I guess,
to give context to why I chose this,
this is one of my favorite doujin artists.
It's an artist called Fuga and I don't-
- I fucking love Fuga.
- Yeah, I didn't know
how well known he was,
but this man is to me,
the king of vanilla.
Like this man's like, his art is like,
I would say like about average,
maybe bit above average.
- It's average.
- It's about average, but like
why I love his work so much
is that his like stories and characters
are so fucking good where
there are some points
where I feel like I'm not
even reading a doujin,
I'm just reading a romance
manga with sex scenes in it.
- No, I wanna agree with
you so bad, I want to.
But there was so many
moments where I'm like,
"Nah, bro, this ain't it."
- Is it the incest?
(all laughing)
- Of course it's incest!
- The incest side story, right?
- So, let me explain the story
first and I'll build up to,
you're probably wondering why
is there incest in this story?
Connor didn't even mention incest.
Why is there incest in the story?
Great question, I'll answer why
there's incest in the story.
So in this story, like I said,
you know, she moves into his apartment.
For some reason, he doesn't kick her out
or try to get his dad to kick her out.
He lets her live in there
and they both explain
to each other they're frustrated
because they haven't been able to jack off
because they're both
always around each other.
- [Garnt and Joey] Yeah.
- And so her solution is,
"Well great, I'll just make you nut."
As any good teacher would, apparently.
So they start fucking and
then it becomes a thing.
And you know, it's very honestly,
like I will admit it's quite
attractive up to this point.
It's done very tastefully
considering the fact
that it would be very
illegal and very concerning
in real life.
In doujin form, very tasteful.
I thought it was done
really well, I was on board.
- I would say the reason
for that is because like,
there's a good like 40 to 50 pages
before there's this first sex scene.
- True, true, true.
- And like-
- It's done well,
it's done well.
- It's like, you hear this
premise and you think,
"Okay, I've seen doujins like this before,
they fuck in like the third,
fourth page or something.
No, there is like-
- It was tasteful, it was tasteful.
- There is 40 full pages
of characterization.
And that's the thing, that's
why I love this doujin artist
is because he gives a shit
about characterization.
- I'll say that there was,
he definitely took the time and
again, like I'm saying like,
you know, obviously in real
life, the shit is fucking weird.
But it's doujin, right?
You set the kind of disbelief apart.
And it was done pretty well.
I'd say up to this point,
it's done really well.
What were you gonna say?
- No, I was just gonna say,
I fucking love this one.
- I don't, again, like I was honestly,
I was so into this.
- I was like, this reminds me of like
an early '90s Shonen Jump rom-com.
- Yeah, it does, doesn't it?
- With like the art
and like how it's paced
and like the characterization.
I'm like, I fucking love this, dude.
- I'm not just here to hate, you know?
I agree, it was hot, right?
Up until this point, I was like,
they're hitting every mark, you know?
They've done this about
as tastefully as you can.
A little weird at parts.
- Was it chapter three?
- It might've been chapter three.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- So first of all, right,
we get this whole like,
when the whole reason why they fuck
is 'cause there's a rumor
going around the school
that she's dating a teacher
and the teacher is like.
- Like the vice-principal, right?
- The vice principal.
And the vice principal was like,
"Yeah, we're dating, kid. Get over it."
But he doesn't know they're fucking yet.
And she was like, "No, no,
no, he turned up at a hotel
and he tried to come
onto me. We didn't fuck."
I'm like, all right,
respect. Respect. I get it.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And then out of nowhere
like a fucking Randy Orton
slithering in, his sister
comes into the play
and is like, "By the way, I love him.
I'm gonna fucking him now,"
and then they start fucking.
And I'm like, "What is going on?
Where did this come from?
Why?"
It's like the incest was just like,
"Allow me to introduce myself."
Like, why did this-
- No, it wasn't, allow
me to introduce myself,
it came in like the Kool-Aid man.
It was just like, "Bah!"
- [Connor] Yeah, exactly.
- Incest!
- Like to this day-
- Out of nowhere, they just
start fucking his sister
and then she leaves and it's
never brought up again. Why?
- Well no, no, to-
- Justify it to me. Justify the incest.
- No, no, I'm not justifying-
- Why do you like incest so much?
What the fuck?
- I fucking hated the
incest in this one, okay?
- My God, what the fuck was that?
- The reason I fucking love this one,
teacher, student relationship
done fucking tastefully as fuck.
Okay, chapter three, like she
doesn't fuck the main guy.
For some reason like,
there is just this like,
one of his classmates
comes in and is just like,
"I've run away from home."
- That's right.
- That was weird too.
- My sister's harassing me,
all right, like that one.
- To correct what Connor
said, the sister doesn't fuck
the main guy. It's just
these two side characters
who's the brother, sister
who just randomly fuck
for no fucking reason.
I don't know why it's there either.
- It's not the main character?
- No, no, no.
- It's the main character's friend.
- It looks so much like him.
(all laughing)
- It's the main character but less chad.
- Yeah, yeah, like the main
character's friends shows up
and he says, "I've run away from home."
And then he finds out.
- Your sister fucked me.
- Yeah, "My sister's been harassing me."
And then so-
- This is even more concerning
'cause it has absolutely
nothing to do with the plot.
- The main story, right.
- That's what I'm saying, it's
just like a fucking T-bone.
- So his friend finds out
that the teacher and student
are living together and he's like,
"Oh, okay, that's fine, whatever."
And then the sister
comes along and was like,
the sister comes to the
teacher and is like,
"Do you know where my little brother is?
I heard he went to your place."
Or something along those lines.
And so the sister comes in and she's like,
"This is mine. He is mine."
And then she-
- And she's like, "I don't
even know who he is."
- Don't know who you are.
- And then the little brother starts like,
and then she starts fucking
sucking his dick or something
in front of the teacher and
the teacher's just there
being like-
(Garnt laughs)
- She's like, "All right,
you guys, you do you."
- The teacher's just like
fucking Mike Wazowski's face.
She's like-
(Joey laughing)
- This is why I was like,
"What the fuck was that?"
Like, I was literally
into this. Headset meme.
I literally like, "What is this?"
Like, why do they do this?
Like every time you get
into it, a random side story
comes up that has
absolutely fucking nothing
to do with the story and it's shit.
- I thought that side story
was fucking hilarious.
- But it takes you out of it.
- No, it was funny.
- Yeah, but in the wrong way. It was shit!
- No, no, no.
- I mean, I mean, it was so out of place
for like the rest of the doujin.
- 'Cause it's only one chapter.
- It's only one chapter.
It's a side story that I don't know
why the side story's in here.
- Put it at the end, put it at the end.
Don't ruin the flow.
- Because it literally had
no effects on the story
and they don't call back to
the characters at fucking all.
Like, I don't know why
this side story is in here.
But the point is, like the reason this is
one of my favorites is
that the relationship
between the student and the teacher
is like handled so well.
- Wholesome as fuck.
- And it's just like, you
can never read a Fuga doujin
and just not come out just like
with a warm, fuzzy feeling.
- I agree with that.
- What, what, what?
- What are you laughing at Connor?
Why are you laughing Connor?
- Because there's a few.
I gotta stop you right there.
I will stop you right there.
There is one moment where I was like,
"Oh, I don't know about that one, chief."
Where she's like, "Guys,
I have an announcement
to the school. I've been
fucking one of the students."
And I'm like, "I don't
think that's a good idea.
Really don't think this is a good idea."
- But like, it's completely
in character though, isn't it?
Like they've built her up as just someone
who just doesn't give a fuck.
- Yeah, but I'm thinking,
I'm sitting here like,
"All right, all right."
- She did it for love.
- I respect it. I respect it. I do, I do.
But think about your career a little bit.
- No, she doesn't care.
- You're not employed.
You've literally just admitted
to a criminal offense,
I'm pretty sure, like
in front of everyone.
- No dude, she was just like,
"I love this guy so much,
I'm willing to quit my job."
- "Your honor, it was love."
"All right, you've been
sentenced to 10 years in jail.
Get out of here."
- That's why it's wholesome as fuck.
- Wholesome as fuck?
- She sacrificed her
career to declare her love.
And I'm just like-
- Exactly.
- I'm just like, this is
a doujin, I don't care.
I don't care about the
legal ramifications.
She obviously didn't get any.
The point is that like, it
was building up to a point.
- Listen, I will admit, the
ending was somewhat sweet.
I will admit.
A part of me was just like,
"Did you really have to
announce it to the school?
Was this really necessary?"
Could you not have just quit?
- That's the dramatic scene.
- It's not like the Shrek fucking wedding.
You don't have to be like, "Lord Farquaad,
you cannot marry her
because I'm going to marry."
You don't need that, it
really doesn't add anything.
You could have just been like,
"You know what, I'll see you after school.
Graduate and we'll fuck."
That could have been the end.
- But that's boring.
- Yeah.
- Is it though?
- I mean it was dramatic.
- It's the drama, you need the drama.
- You need the drama, you
need the spice, motherfucker.
- That's the POG moment where you're like,
"Ooh, I can't believe she just said that."
- Like when he confessed to her
and she just went, "I know."
I'm just like, "Oh, shit son,
she did not just say that."
- Well, I mean, she'd
literally been fucking
riding this boy's dick for 10 months,
of course she likes her.
That's how this shit goes.
- But that's what I
loved about this doujin,
is that it reads like a '90s rom-com,
because there's so many moments
like that in '90s rom-coms
that I've read where I'm just
like, "I mean, of course."
Like, "Of course you would do that."
- I was so fucking invested
in these characters' relationship
more so than like any
other doujin I've read.
Apart from his other works,
I mean, the only reason I
really chose this was of course,
Garnt, teacher-student relationship.
Of course, I'm gonna fucking love that.
- Of course, yeah.
- I mean, you know, as
taboo as it is in real life,
it's very attractive in fictional works.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't think about
the legal ramifications
when I read doujins.
- Sometimes I do.
I'm sitting there and
I'm like, "Fuck dude,
like how many years am
I getting for this?"
- Like this isn't even his
like most highly rated works.
There's like one which I would say
is like the "Tsuredure
Children" of hentai.
If you remember "Tsuredure Children,"
it's like an anime that
focuses on different couples
kind of like getting together
and it's wholesome as fuck.
And his work is basically like that
but just with the fucking included, right?
You get the same kind of
character development,
you get the same kind of
care in the characterization
as you would in any other fucking manga.
- I would say there's
big props to making me
actually give a about the story
despite the weird side story.
Again, I really wanna know
what the thought process was.
I'd love to have been
in the board meeting.
I wish I was there.
- I thought that was fucking hilarious.
- I was, but it also took me out of it.
- I was like, halfway
through reading this chapter,
I was like, I know this is
gonna have no ramifications
on the story, but it's
just hilarious to read.
- I was just like, 'cause I
knew when I recommended this
that it was that scene that
was gonna get brought up.
- Of course it is, how could I not?
- I knew it was just gonna be that moment
where it's just like,
"Garnt, is this your man?"
I'm just like, "This is not
my man, this is not my man."
- [Connor] This is literally your man.
- Come get your mans. Come get your mans.
- All I'm saying, all right,
is that two out of three
have incest, Garnt. What's up with that?
What's up with that?
You know, I mean, whatever.
- He likes it, man. Leave the man alone.
- This is good. I like it
'cause I get to be the judge,
jury, and executioner here
and I didn't have to share my taste.
- You didn't have to show your taste?
- I don't have any taste.
- We roasted you enough
in the hentai episode.
- Listen, I put "Mother
Knows Breast" up, come on,
I've been roasted enough for a lifetime.
I stand by my words.
But yeah, I mean this was-
- Out of 10?
- What did I give it out of 10?
Let me see what I gave it.
Seven out of 10.
- Not bad.
- Not that bad.
- I thought the good moments
were very, very good.
The story was pretty damn good.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Few moments where I thought,
"Ah, you know, whatever."
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And a few moments where I'm like,
"All right, a little too much keenness
from this lady in the start."
And I'm like, "There's no way.
Why are you into this kid?
Is there any reason why?
Is it purely that-"
- I don't even think she
was into the kid at first.
- [Connor] Really?
- Because-
- She's just joshing around.
- Yeah.
- What kind of woman josh around?
Hehe, gonna fuck around and
live in your apartment, bruh.
- She's like early 20s.
She doesn't give a fuck.
- Like the reason that there
was like, they used the cat
analogy so much was because
she would just basically
was a stray cat.
That was like the analogy.
- [Connor] I get it, I get it.
- Right, when I'm just like,
she doesn't give a fuck.
- Again, good story though.
- It was the first time
where I read a doujin
and I looked at like a
character and I was like,
"You're not even hot,
you're just cute as fuck."
- Yeah, honestly, the
reason this is my favorite
of his works is because I fucking-
- Like you got the cutest
fucking personality.
- I fucking feel the teacher's,
like, I love the fucking teacher, man.
- Yeah, I think she's cute as fuck.
- Yeah, she is cute as fuck.
- The fang. The fucking fang. I was like.
- The fangs?
- Bro, that does it for me.
- Seven out of 10.
(all laughing)
- All right, but what's most
important is this final one.
- [Connor] Okay.
- It's neither Garnt or my recommendation,
or rather it's both of
our recommendations.
- It's both our recommendation.
- They just wanted to scar me.
- We were never going
to do a doujin episode
without talking about "Metamorphosis."
- One of the most legendary
doujins out there.
- Okay and Connor's never read it.
- Okay, before we start,
I got something to say.
I have a confession to make, guys.
- Go on.
- Oh no, what are you gonna say, Garnt?
Fuck.
- I have, before this,
never read "Metamorphosis."
- Really?
- Yes.
- Wow.
- "Metamorphosis" has been
my "Full Metal Alchemist."
(all laughing)
- All it took was an
episode to make you do it.
- Congratulations, you did it.
- I just needed.
- It takes 10 fucking minutes
to read, it's not long.
- It's not 10 fucking minutes.
- It's like a 20, 30 minute read.
- Yeah, yeah, but it was the one where
I'm just like, people have
talked about it so much
that I had just been putting it off.
So it was that one hentai
where I'm just like,
"I will read 'Metamorphosis'
when I am ready to read
'Metamorphosis.'"
- I will say, for all
I've heard about this,
I almost expected it to be
more fucked up than it was.
Did you feel that way?
It was pretty fucked up.
- Okay.
- But because of the reputation it had,
I expected it to be-
- You over-hyped yourself.
- I thought it was gonna
be even worse than it was.
- So did you just hype up the
fucked up-ness in your head?
- Well, you know, I mean,
I've been an anime fan for a long time.
You hear about this constantly.
It's referenced constantly.
It's been that one fucked
up thing, you know and I-
- It's fucked up for a vanilla audience.
- Yeah, I've watched the final
season of "Game of Thrones."
I know true disappointment,
and this is kind of what
it felt like a little bit.
I was like, this is fucked.
Don't get me wrong, it's very fucked up.
- It is fucked.
- But I almost expected something worse,
like I almost expected like
absolutely horrific shit.
- I think it's because
you already put your foot
in the doujin and like hentai world.
- [Connor] Yeah, I mean, I know.
- This is like Grade A fucked
up for someone who's like,
never stepped foot into that, right?
- I feel like I've seen S-tier fucked up
and this is A-tier fucked up.
Like it's very fucked up
and very uncomfortable.
Maybe it's just more accessible.
I'm not really sure why this
one has gotten a notoriety.
- I think it's because this was one of,
I think this was just that
one doujin that really
just got around, I guess,
for whatever reason it is.
And I'm like.
- Should we explain the premise?
- Yeah, why don't you?
- "Metamorphosis" is
- Why don't you explain?
- A very, very well-known doujin.
- [Joey] Yes.
- About a girl who, you know,
she's not the prettiest girl
out there and then she gets
a makeover and then suddenly-
- [Garnt] Literally takes off her glasses.
Takes off her glasses,
puts on a bit of makeup,
- Becomes hot.
- Becomes hot and then guys
are suddenly attracted.
- You have seen this
beginning panel somewhere.
If you're in the anime community,
- You've always seen it.
- You've seen this somewhere.
- It's iconic as fuck, even
I know what this panel is
and then I didn't know
any of the other panel,
which is, this is the before
and this is the after.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Completely different character.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And then this character is just shocked
that guys are now paying attention to her
and that they wanna fuck her.
And so she starts fucking these guys,
and it gets really derailed really fast.
Yeah, it's a big yikes of a read.
I mean, how do I explain it?
I mean, here's, okay. Let me just,
I put some notes down while I was reading.
- [Joey] Yeah, go on.
- Seems normal so far. Not
fond of how his dad reacted
to her makeup, of her dad
reacting to her makeup.
- What scene was that?
- Makeover, makeover, not gonna lie.
- Oh yeah.
- Chapter three.
- So she gets a make-over and
the father's like, "Oh, okay."
(Garnt laughing)
I was like, "I don't like that."
- You won't believe what happens next.
- I was like, I do not like that.
I do not like that look he gave.
This does not mean good things.
And unfortunately, I was correct.
- Top 10 foreshadowing moments.
- Literally, WatchMojo, you can take this
from "The Top 10 Foreshadowing
Moments in Anime."
Yeah, so, you know, a kind of sleazy dude
kind of uses her for sex, you know,
and then gives her drugs.
- Yeah, I think the biggest
aspect of the story,
which I've never seen in
any other doujinshi before
was the drug angle, right?
- Yeah, it was pretty
uncomfortable, not gonna lie.
It was pretty uncomfortable.
- Yeah, where he was like,
so she puts on makeup,
she has her makeover
and then she finds this douche bag guy
who basically gives her a drug and-
- It's kind of like a Mandy
rip off kind of thing.
- Yeah, yeah, and basically
she experiences the best sex
of her, or just one of the
best experiences of her life.
- Literally the first time.
- She's a virgin then and she just becomes
kind of a nymphomaniac, right?
Where she just-
- And a drug addict.
- Yeah, well, a sex addict and
a drug addict at this point,
right, where she's addicted to the sex
and she's addicted to the drugs,
and she's addicted to the sex and drugs.
And then this, it just kind
of spirals down from there.
It is like, it is a downward
curve from like chapter one.
- But you almost feel like
when the character is
like this disconnected
and like barely gives you
any signs of wanting to,
I don't know, like it
feels so forced at times,
this decline of mental
state where it's like,
"All right, you're just
doing the fucking best
of depression hits at
this point or something."
You know what I mean?
Like, it's literally,
you're just trying to get,
I feel like they're just making things bad
for the sake of it.
Like a lot of the time
I was like, "I guess."
Like there was a moment
in it where I was like,
I dunno, 'x' to doubt
on that one where like-
- Which point, which point?
- So, it was in the school,
where during the story,
they know that she went to a hotel.
Okay, I suppose I should back up.
So she has this boyfriend
who's kind of a scumbag,
gives her drugs and then
she kind of wants money.
So she starts fucking an
old guy who gives her money.
A little disturbing and
the sex scene is really-
- Ugly bastard tag.
- Literally, really, it's
not an uncomfortable-
It's quite uncomfortable,
what am I saying?
It's very uncomfortable.
(Joey laughing)
I didn't mean to say "not uncomfortable."
It's very uncomfortable.
And then for some reason,
one of the students finds out
that she went to this place.
So naturally, all of the
boys together decide,
"Well, let's all get blow jobs from her.
That's what me and the boys do at school."
It's like-
- Yeah, of course.
- First of all, never gonna happen.
But also that was the
part where I was like,
"Ah, I feel like this is kind of like,
ah, this is a little extra."
That was where I was like, "I
get it. It's very depressing."
But I was like, "This feels
really forced," this part.
I'm like, you're making
this sad for the sake of it.
Do you agree with that whole school part?
I'm like, "This is a bit of a stretch."
- I mean, it's just like a trope
that I've seen in so many doujins.
- And they all start
fucking her and I'm like,
"Name one school kid that minds
showing his dick to anyone,
let alone fucking someone
in front of his friend."
- You'd be surprised in Japan.
- I don't know, man. I don't know, man.
- This is a culture that is grown up
on just seeing each other's
dicks in the Onsen, right?
That's like.
(Garnt chuckles)
- It is.
- Yeah, just probably another
day in the office, right?
- That doesn't mean they wanna
fuck the same fucking girl
in front of each other.
- No, no, no.
- It's such a stretch that I'm like,
"Ah, I feel like they're just doing this
for the sake of it."
- I mean, you say it's a stretch,
but again, it's like such a
trope that you see in doujins
where it's like-
- Yeah, yeah, I guess so.
- It happens all the time,
it's not even like surprising.
- But I guess when it's used in a way,
it's like, feel sorrow for
this girl, feel like sadness.
I'm like, "No, I mean."
- I mean that wasn't even
the part where I felt sadness
at all, it was,
- Oh God, I mean.
- It was after that.
- Like, what I would say is,
this is like the "Requiem
for a Dream" of hentai.
And I didn't think I would
say that in like a sentence,
but it's a thing, it is a thing, this is.
- So, after she sleeps with
this old guy for money,
after she gets blackmailed by
the other kids in her school
to have sex with them and
do all this other stuff,
which is really horrifying,
it's not portrayed very well.
It is portrayed very horrifyingly.
Her dad wants a piece of the action.
Now this is where I'm
like, "For fuck's sake."
This is just like, this is
like, literally the saying
"My day can't get any worse."
This is literally it, so I'm like, God.
What do I even say about this thing?
This is so fucked up that
I'm like, "Oh my God,"
like "What, why?"
And then she fucks, the dad
fucks her and it goes on.
And the mum blames her
and I'm like, "Really?"
(Garnt laughing)
Really, like you were married
to this man for how long
and you think it's your daughter's fault?
Come on, come the fuck on. No way.
I bet 99% of wives would
be like, "Men you're out.
I don't care what happened,
I don't care who tempted
who, you're fucking out.
You are the problem, you
should fucking know better."
I'm like, that's where I was like,
"Hmm, all right, okay.
Okay, maybe, maybe."
I'm like, "ah."
- Maybe, I'll see where this goes.
- I don't know about this move, chief.
I don't know, could you
see a world where the mum
would be like, "I blame you,
daughter, for fucking dad."
- I mean, fuck, I don't know, man.
(all laughing)
I don't know anyone who's
been in that situation.
How the fuck am I supposed to know?
You never know, there might
be, who the fuck knows?
- Yeah, yeah.
- What do you think there?
This is just fucking weird.
This one was fucking weird, uncomfortable.
I'm like, I get why it's got a reputation,
but I was just like, "Fuck."
- Oh no, it is absolutely fucked up
and it's one of those doujins
where it's not supposed
to be enjoyed in the conventional
way of enjoying a doujin.
- You know some sick fuck did.
- Of course, yes.
- I'ma fucking say it, I think
this doujin's a masterpiece.
- Thank you, thank you.
- I was just like-
- What is wrong with you?
- I have not-
- No, no.
- Not because I thought it was hot,
- I raised this boy.
(Garnt laughing)
- This is just like, "I
google every depressing thing
that could happen in life.
I put it in a doujin."
How is that a masterpiece?
- I have never been so
engrossed in a doujin before
where, like I was turning every page.
- Oh fuck off, fuck off!
- I was just like-
'Cause I was thinking,
(Joey clapping)
- You are chatting out of your ass.
- Where is this doujin gonna go next?
I'm 100% serious when I was just like.
- I literally saw it from like,
the moment she met this guy, I'm like,
I bet just fucked up after
fucked up shit is gonna happen.
The moment he gave her drugs, I'm like,
"I know where this is going.
This is just kind of-"
- It has the greatest shonen
battle of all time, dude.
Who is going to win?
- Woman versus drugs, fuck!
- One innocent girl or one spiky boy.
(Joey laughs)
- No, because like I tried to come,
I feel like you came in with
like a lot of preconceived
notions where you're just
like, "This is fucked up.
I'm ready for this."
- Listen, if this was a movie
or a TV show or anything,
this would be like, just like bait tier.
This is just baiting.
This is just so lazy in
terms of how little they try
to sell this as like a
realistic journey that I'm like,
you know, we've had movies
about stuff like this
that are fucked up that have
done this so much better
that I'm like-
- Especially "Requiem
for a Dream" like that.
- Just because this is an
doujin format and it's literally
the only one that's like,
"How about we be depressing?"
You know, it's like, I
don't want to give it
props for that 'cause like-
- I give it props for that.
- I think it's a bit more than that.
- Yeah, but I think it's a little more.
- Maybe I'm being a little too harsh,
but I feel like this has been
done before in other places.
- Because I feel like
"Metamorphosis" has like,
well now it has to battle with it
being like the meme doujin, right?
'Cause it's like people don't judge it
on its own merits anymore.
People judge it being like,
"Ha ha, I've seen this
been memed everywhere
as like the big thing that
people recommend to people
to like fuck them up and stuff like that."
And it's like one thing
that's like, I don't like
is that people in like
the hentai community
or what I've seen, people are just like,
"I've seen more fucked up shit than this.
I've seen worse things than this."
And I'm just like, "Of course you have,
I too watch 'Euphoria.'
I too have seen some
of the shit that Sydney
has recommended and fucking reviewed."
Like, I've seen the fucked up shit.
- I've seen his deadly
collection of hentai.
(Garnt laughing)
You know, I did go in.
You know, a part of me obviously
went into this thinking
it was gonna be the most
fucked up thing I've ever seen
in my life 'cause I was recommending it.
But it wasn't that.
Then the other hand, I'm like, you know,
it's almost trying too hard
to make me feel sadness
for this character that
I don't really feel
like they built her up that well.
Like, honestly, personally.
- I thought they built her up really well.
- It was so short and sweet and it's like,
I guess, it felt very
one dimensional to me.
I felt like there wasn't
enough depth to the character.
And then the moment shit
started going wrong.
- Look at us, depth to the
character in a doujin episode.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Listen, listen, listen.
- Look at us, look at us.
- If you want me to give
a shit about this story,
you sit here and say it's a masterpiece.
I'ma sit back and be like,
"Listen, fine I'll talk
about the characters
for one goddamn minute."
- Okay.
- The moment started going wrong for her,
all character development
went out the fucking window.
There was like nothing
was added or introduced.
It was like, all right.
It's like an Apple event.
It's like, "We've seen the iPhone,
we've seen being taken advantage of.
Let me introduce being taken
advantage of by your father."
And it was like,
(Connor clapping)
That's what I felt like.
I felt like I was being condescended to
in terms of the shit that was coming up.
- Okay, because I would
feel like the thing
that I also want to mention is that,
goddamn, Shindo L knows how
to draw a good sex scene.
My fucking God, that's the
thing that's missing, right?
- He's the man.
- Because like, okay, here's the thing.
I think fucking chapter
one awoke something in me.
You're like, you remember
talking about like
that new thing where
you're just like, "Ooh."
- Wait, what is the new thing?
Tell me.
- The new fetish.
- The new fetish is
just like this girl who,
like I've never read a doujin
where like, this sex scene
is like this intense. I'm just like-
- Was that like with the drugs and shit?
- Yeah where-
- In the Karaoke room.
- Yeah, where they introduced the drugs
and it just like enhanced
their experience to a point
where it was just like nothing that
you can ever experience on this Earth.
- I don't know why I didn't
enjoy that scene that much.
I'm not really sure why.
- No, that scene single-handedly
awoke that for me as well.
- I'm just like, why didn't it?
- I'm just like, me reading that scene
was just like fucking
heavy breathing cats.
(Joey laughing)
I'm just like, "Oh, oh God."
- Fogging up your PC monitor.
- Horny grip.
- Jesus Christ, for a second I like,
understood Meilyne for like a second.
And now that's fucking
saying something, right?
Like I didn't know I could feel this way.
And then like chapter three
hit and I'm just like,
I think like my fucking penis shriveled up
and it just inverted
back into my body, right?
(Joey and Connor laughing)
It was just like such
a whiplash of emotions
that I'm just like, it went
from like, "Oh, that's hot."
to just like, "What
the fuck am I reading?"
- Have you seen that fucking like,
there's a thing in the UK
where they would go and,
it's a TV show, they go and visit tribes?
And there's this one clip,
it's one of my favorite clips.
It's where the guys
like, there's a ceremony
where they invert their penises
and they invert this dude's
penis and he immediately faints.
(all laughing)
I imagine that's what happened.
That's what happened to Garnt.
His penis inverts. He just fucking,
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
at his PC monitor and Sydney's
like, "What happened, Garnt?"
"I was reading 'Metamorphosis.'"
- [Joey] Understandable.
- Understandable.
Here's some Powerade.
(all laughing)
- I mean, honestly, 'cause
I feel like the difference
between me and you was just
like, at a point I was into it
and then I was just like, "Okay,
I am not into it anymore."
But I was like, I was invested in it.
- Maybe that's why it was strong for you,
because it was like, you
were into it at one point.
And then it's like,
(Connor claps)
slaps you on the back of
the head, it's like, stop.
- It's the whiplash of emotion, yes.
- Stop it, that was a
really good clap by the way.
- Like, oh my God.
Like even during like some
of the later chapters,
I'm just like-
- No, no, no.
- [Garnt] No, no, no.
- Don't say it, don't say it.
- No, because like his art
is fucking amazing, right?
I don't know how he draws his
sex scenes to be this intense,
where I'm just like, "I'm feeling emotions
that I've never felt before in my life."
- I was reading this praying,
"I wanna go back to the succubus one."
(Garnt laughing)
I really wanted to just open it.
- Okay, I gotta ask, what do y'all think
about the final chapter?
- Fucked up.
(Joey laughing)
- Because I think, I almost
think now, hearing your guys'
thoughts on it is that
this manga works amazingly,
or doujin works amazingly,
if you get invested
really heavily in the first
part and the first sex scene.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Because then it like, like I said,
it hits you in the back of the head.
It's like, "No, don't be horny."
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- It's bad. Horny bad.
- I mean, it like, gave me
such a mess of emotions, right?
Because I'm just like,
"I know I shouldn't be horny right now.
This is fucking depressing as shit.
This is fucked up," you know?
- I didn't like the guy at
all and I think that's why,
like I couldn't. This guy was a fucking-
- No, I didn't like the guy at all.
- No, no, no you're not
supposed to like the guy.
- Yeah, but to me, it's
like, the whole hotness
of the sex is the duo dynamic.
- Look, okay, someone
who is that depressed
shouldn't be making those
kinds of facial expressions.
You can fucking frame some
of the facial expressions.
- What do you mean by that, Garnt?
- Like, honestly-
- Let's unpack that a little.
- Okay, okay.
- Let's jump right into it.
- Let's talk about the art of that.
- He's gonna need another drink.
(Garnt laughing)
- Let's talk about the
art of the ahegao, right?
- I'm not fond of it, you know.
I've been oversaturized to it.
- Yeah, you've been oversaturized to it.
- I think we all have.
- We all have, right?
But like his, like ahegao
faces are some of the most
unique fucking ahegao faces I've ever seen
in all of hentai.
- It's Asanagi and Shindo L.
- I'm a man of the church though,
that's not enough to
make me quiver, you know?
I don't see that.
My will's not compromised by
such ill-thought ideas of sex.
- I'm sorry Connor, that
this art piece was so good
that it made me question.
It made me question it for a second.
And then I was just like,
"No, I'm back to it.
This is awful, this is depraved."
- God just fucking
imagine the fucking name
of the clip for this fucking thing.
Garnt thought fucking "Metamorphosis"
was the fucking Mona Lisa
of doujins or some shit.
- I personally think it's
the Mona Lisa of doujins.
- No.
- Okay, okay.
The reason why like I
was so engrossed in it
is because it was such like.
- You love incest and there's incest in it
at some point, Garnt.
So clearly that's why you like it.
- It was such a fucking mess of emotions,
and it was like an
emotional up and down, like-
- It was just down from the start.
I knew the moment she was like,
"I can't make good friends."
I'm like, "Oh no, that's-"
- The only other time
- That's gonna lead
to bad decisions.
- I felt that depressed
reading something was "Oyasumi Punpun."
- And also, okay so-
- I've not read "Oyasumi Punpun."
- This is the "Oyasumi Punpun" of doujin.
- I also wanna put it into
perspective that I just read
like three and a half
hours of porn before this.
So reading this last was not
a good way to end my day.
(Joey laughing)
I was already quite
done with reading porn.
And then, you have to bear in mind,
there was probably no
way I was gonna find any,
even if it was the hottest.
- That's what you get
for doing your homework
the day before it's due.
- I was given the thing the day before.
I was given this two days ago.
So, you know, I think
that also didn't help,
'cause there was no way
I was ever gonna find
any of these things attractive
'cause I was pretty much,
you know, I was pretty
done with reading porn.
- [Joey] You've read.
- I've read so much.
- [Joey] You did you
year's quota of reading.
- I literally read like, what I think
is like a normal person's
like month worth of porn
in one day, you know?
So I was pretty exhausted and
the fact that this came up
and I just saw right
through it right away.
I knew exactly what they were
gonna do right from the start
and I was just like, you know, it's fine.
You know, I see what you're trying to do,
you're trying to make me sad
and I don't appreciate it.
(Joey laughing)
Frankly.
- I want a happy ending.
- It's not done well, you know?
The whole, like the moment
that her dad looked at her,
I'm like, "I see what
you're doing here, buddy
and I'm not a fan."
- Your next line is...
- I actually,
- I'm not a fan.
- We keep talking about the dad,
but I think the dad is the
worst part of the doujin.
- [Connor] It's definitely.
- 'Cause it was just like,
for me reading the dad episode
was just like, let's just
throw in something fucked up.
- It is literally, I would
rather eat my own toenails
than read them again.
- But like what, like it
was after the dad doujin,
the dad chapter part when I'm just like,
"Yo, this is really
engrossing as a story."
- I knew it was going there.
The moment he gave her a drug, I'm like,
"He's literally gonna sell her later on
and use drugs for it."
- [Garnt] Yeah, of course.
- It was so obvious it was going there.
And so when they went there, I was like,
I was not even surprised.
The dad thing caught me off guard.
I had a feeling it might happen
and then when it did happen,
I'm like, for fuck sake.
- Yeah.
- Goddamn it. Goddamn it.
- 'Cause like to me, it was just like,
it was just the feeling
of just being like,
"This is the most depraved shit.
I shouldn't feel horny at
all with this situation."
- Are people jacking off to this?
- I don't think so.
I don't know, probably someone is.
- Probably someone.
- Vsauce.
- 'Cause the thing is, it
was that emotion juxtaposed
between how amazing the sex scenes were.
'Cause like, out of context.
- 'X' to doubt on this.
- Out of context, out of context.
- No I don't think the sex
scenes were all that good.
- The art was fucking amazing.
- Half of it was fucking ugly bastards.
How am I supposed to get behind that shit?
- I mean, it wasn't all ugly bastards.
- It wasn't all ugly bastards.
- Okay, so it was, we
had two very big scenes
with older men.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And it was very gross because-
- I mean, there were six chapters and two,
maybe three of them were ugly bastards.
- Which frankly, one is too many.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
for me, personally.
So the fact that I read this
shit and I thought it's bad
enough she's fucking some
random dude for money
who is literally the ugliest man on earth,
and then next it's like fucking Smash Bros
introducing a new
fighter, her fucking dad,
into this fucked up story already,
which is already depressing
as fuck because everyone
in the fucking school has had a go at her.
And it's just like, that shit alone,
I was like, you know what?
Yeah, sure Japanese kids are fucked up,
but like, this is too much.
This would never happen.
No way in any school would
this ever happen, ever.
- Well, it's interesting
because like, I interviewed
Shindo L a couple of years
ago and we talked about this,
'cause I want us to know.
I was like, what inspired "Metamorphosis?"
And he said that, because he was born
and raised in New York.
So he was like, "I heard
and saw so many stories
that were similar to this."
- [Connor] Right.
- And he was like, "I
wanted to bring light to it
'cause otherwise no one
fucking talks about it."
- I bet this shit has
happened like, separately.
Like all of these individual things
- No, no, absolutely.
- Have definitely happened.
- This isn't based off real life.
- No, I know, I know, but
the fact that like you string
these all together to a
point where I'm just like,
I suspend my disbelief and I'm
like, "Yeah, I don't know."
- Oh, it's not supposed to be realistic,
but it's supposed to be...
- Yeah, I know, I know.
- It's basically, I think, in my opinion,
it was, Shindo L being like,
"Look, this shit happens."
- But like, I think about
movies that fucked me up,
and I think "That could be
me. I can make that mistake.
I could be in that situation."
And this one, I was like.
- Well yeah, 'cause you're not a chick.
- But even then, like, I feel
like it was trying too hard.
- I think the most
fantastical element of it
was how much he enjoyed the sex.
'Cause I feel, that was
the big difference between.
- That was also an uncomfortable part
'cause I'm like, "Is this is
good, is it what she wants?"
I don't know.
- Well that's the one.
- That's the most interesting element.
- That to me is what like, drew me in,
was like the fact that she
enjoyed the sex so much,
which I know is like unrealistic.
- But with her dad?
Vsauce music, what?
- No, no, no, that's the point, right?
Where it's just like, it's
such like a mess of emotions
that it's just like,
you have no grounding.
- It questions your
morality the entire time.
- There's like no grounding
on this kind of situation
'cause personally, I don't know anyone
who's fucked their dads.
(all laughing)
- I'm glad, Garnt.
- I personally know of four
people who have done it.
- And I kind of wanna keep
it that way, you know?
Like that's just me.
I don't know if that's a hot take,
but like I hope that that never happens
to any-fucking-body, you know?
- Yeah.
- [Connor] It's fucked.
It's fucked.
- But I mean, yeah,
that's the point, is it's fucked.
It's fiction, right?
But like the thing that
drew me in was that
it was just these fucked up situations
juxtaposed between sex scenes
that she obviously really
enjoyed at the time, right?
And I'm just like, "Yo,
this is like really weird,
this is like a weird car crash
of different fucking things
I shouldn't be feeling right now"
but I'm just like, I
don't know how to like,
I'm still like processing it now
because it's like the only time.
The reason I call this a masterpiece
is that it's the only time
I've felt this emotion
that I'm trying to
describe right now, right?
Normally, you get depressed.
Normally, you get horny.
You don't talk about
depression boner, do you?
Like that does that just
doesn't happen, right?
But "Metamorphosis" is just
these two fucking things
that shouldn't coexist together,
- Coexisting together.
- They're coexisting together.
I'm just like what?
- And that's why I think
it's brilliant as well.
It's because he took such
a fucking risk with this.
Where he was like, this
could have easily just been
like a weird thing that no
one would have picked up
and then just like brushed under
all of the "Oh, okay,
that's fucking weird,
let's not talk about that" pile of doujins
that are out there, but
there was just again,
he just presented it in a
way where it was just like,
you came for the horny,
but you're gonna stay for the depression,
whether you like it or not.
And like, I don't know any other doujin
that's managed to do that
and managed to make me stay
the entire time until the end.
- You ever seen the Shia
LaBeouf movie "Nymphomaniac?"
- No, I haven't.
That's like the three
hour long one, right?
- It's like, there's two parts to it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I felt like that was a
really uncomfortable depiction
of a woman who's addicted to sex.
- [Joey] Right.
- I felt like that was
really somewhat well done.
- I thought that's an interesting movie.
- It's a very hard watch.
- Yeah, really?
- It's very long.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's very uncomfortable.
- It's that fucking like,
really avant garde director.
- Yeah it is.
- What's his name?
- It's one of those
things where it's like,
it really reminds you, like,
you think you're cool with sex
until you see it in
really uncomfortable ways
and you're like, ah, yeah.
- It's the Lars Von Trier
movie, that's right.
- I kind of have weird thoughts about,
'cause it really makes you be like,
"Oh, you're comfortable sex?
Bet."
- [Joey] Yeah.
(Joey laughing)
- And I feel like, you know.
Having experienced that
kind of weird shit,
I feel like going into
this, I'm like, yeah,
I can kind of buy why she's into it,
but also I feel like it's been done better
in different places almost.
Not saying that movie did
it better essentially,
but I feel like I've seen it
done in a way where I'm like,
I think this is done slightly
more realistic to the point
where I'm like, I
believe it. I believe it.
- Yeah, right. But it's hard to like,
I get it, how like, you know,
movies like "Nymphomaniac"
probably did this whole thing
better, but at the same time,
"Nymphomaniac" has the upside
of being more realistic
by using real actors.
- [Connor] That's true, that's true.
- I mean, we shouldn't have,
like, the biggest thing-
- It's hard to, for me personally
who's never read doujins
to see this and be like,
"Damn that's fucking,
that's art, man, that's..."
- Yeah I get it,
- This is deep, this is deep,
- It's a tall hurdle, we get it.
- I mean, we literally just
chucked you in the deep end
and just like try to see
it's like tried to see
if you could pull your way out.
- Yeah, I mean, it's like
I'm not used to this genre.
- I mean, I don't think anyone is.
- All these kinds of tropes in here.
And then there's this girl
who I'm supposed to believe
is this kind of well done character.
And I'm like, yeah, I
don't believe it, man.
Personally, at least.
- I mean, at least you gave it a go.
At least you can now say
you read "Metamorphosis."
- I've read it. I'm not
proud of that fact, Joey.
I wanna undo the reading that I've done.
- So what would you give it out of 10?
- In terms of what?
- In terms of just like
how you felt about it.
- Four.
- Four?
- It's an interesting read.
- And what will you give it?
- 10.
- Hell yeah.
- Fuck off!
- What does Sydney think of it?
- I don't know what Sydney thinks of it.
- You should ask her
what she thinks of it.
- Frankly, I'm afraid to ask.
- She'll be like, "It's the hottest shit.
That scene where the dad fucks?"
- The chapter with the dad?
- "Yo, I nutted."
- I have heard too many
things that have worried me
in the past few months
with my relationship,
that I'm kind of afraid to
ask her opinion of like,
any hentai I right now.
- So I guess we'll leave
it at that then, huh?
Jesus Christ.
- I mean, I appreciate
you guys introducing me
to the wonderful world of
(overlapping chatter and laughter)
- So has this experience
changed your perspective at all?
- Well, I mean, I still
have my preferred methods.
- Right, right, right.
- I got my systems in place.
- But would you ever,
in your like, off time,
go back to like try another doujin?
- Yeah if I was recommended a doujin
that was highly praised,
I would go and read it.
I mean, it's not too difficult,
but hopefully it's not too long.
- Yeah.
- I would say the biggest
appeal about reading doujins
or highly rated doujinshi is like,
I mean, you've talked about
finding that one hentai
that's fucking like the diamond
in the pool of shit, right?
There's so much choice with doujinshi
because there's obviously so much, right?
- Infinite amount of tags.
- There's way more choice
than there is for hentai.
And you can find way more doujins
that are like specifically
garnered to your choice.
- I believe it, I believe it.
I just really enjoy voice acting so much.
And especially in that manner,
I really enjoy what it adds to it.
I feel like it helps sell
my believability on it.
- To me, the best tag you
can possibly get is plot.
Plot is the best spice.
- Isn't it tragic that it
has to be a tag though?
It's not a given that everything has plot.
- No, I don't want plot in mine.
- Some are like, no, no, no,
I don't want the plumber turning up today.
I don't want the pizza
man delivering a pizza.
- The fact that we're
talking about the plumber
and the pizza man just shows
how fucking devoid of plot
every fucking porno is that we've gotten
this kind of mentality
where it's just like,
"Yo, plot's kind of hot," you know?
Knowing the context of
why people are fucking,
that's kind of hot, you know?
Is that such a hot take?
- Me not being a fucking monkey
and just scratching my nuts
to people fucking, you know?
Great, fantastic. You know?
Wow.
- [Joey] My God.
Well, I'm just glad,
Connor, that we managed
to finally do this episode.
'Cause we've been talking
about doing this episode
for quite a while now.
We were like, two out
of three love doujin.
Monkey man over here doesn't wanna read.
- I feel at this point we
should just make it like a bi-
is it bi-yearly, bi-yearly?
- [Joey And Garnt] Bi-yearly.
- Is that twice a year?
- Yeah.
- A doujin and hentai episode.
- This is like about six months
after the hentai episode.
We'll do another hentai
episode in six months.
- My God, it's already been six months?
- Yeah, I know, right?
- [Connor] My God.
God we just talk so
fucking much, don't we?
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
I can't believe.
- Honestly, this has been
such a fucking episode.
It's such a fucking fun episode to film.
- A fucking episode. It
has been a fucking episode.
- This has been a fucking
episode. That's what it's been.
- You know, the succubus one,
I'm praying gets a Pink Pineapple.
- Oh yeah, so out of the
seven, what's your favorite?
- Can I rank them in order?
- Sure.
- All right, "Metamorphosis," zero.
"Metamorphosis" is the worst one.
- At least favorite to most favorite.
- So "Metamorphosis."
- All right, okay.
So "Metamorphosis" is
by far the worst one.
Very close, second last place.
The fucking Oreimo one.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Fuck that one. Fuck that one!
- So that's what, Garnt
in the bottom so far?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I will say that probably after that is,
ooh, ah, it's gotta be the first one.
- "Dorei Usagi."
- Yeah, that one I wasn't too fond of.
And then third, I guess, is,
this is difficult. "Seikatsu."
- "Seikatsu Shuukan."
- [Joey] Okay, okay.
- Shota.
- The shota one, yeah.
- Fourth,
I'll give it to the sensei one.
- [Joey And Garnt] Okay.
- Fifth, I'll give it to "Pisu Hame."
And first place I give to succubus.
- Wow, that's-
- So two of yours are my favorite.
- That's pretty balanced, then.
- That's pretty balanced actually, yeah.
That's not bad.
- Oh, you recommended succubus one, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So, yeah, I'd say-
- "Pisu Hame" is my one.
- Yeah, I'd say you both gave
me, you know, I was shocked.
I was expecting worse from you.
I was expecting loli
orc gang bangs from Joey
and from you Garnt, I was
expecting the whole family
fucking each other, frankly.
- I mean, we could have
recommended that to you but like.
- [Connor] Next time, I guess.
- We got pretty close with
the Oreimo one, right?
- Yeah.
- The whole family came
out for fun with that one.
Fuck me.
- And you haven't finished "Pisu Hame,"
so I'm just gonna leave it at that.
- The thing is we can
only recommend three.
So like when you're choosing
three doujinshi that's like,
a fucking hard choice.
It's like choosing between your children.
I was just like, I
wanted to recommend like
one of the top tier milf ones,
but I'm just like,
there's not enough space.
- Next time, you can
recommend me like one good one
and two ones that you
know I'll fucking hate.
That'll be fun.
- Honestly, you know what you can do?
Give us a list of tags
and we'll find you some.
- Milf, milf, milf milf,
step-mom, step-mom, step-mom
- Step-mom, milf, "Mother Knows Breast."
I don't know.
- It's likely I don't like incest,
but-
- But-
- I'd like to tell you boys
that I'm gonna go here,
I'm gonna go home today a
changed man, reading doujins,
but I'm not.
(Joey laughs)
I'm definitely not.
- Next one is the aruga episode.
So, we gotta recommend
him some aruga episodes.
- No, 'cause they're like 10 hours long.
I can't do that.
- No they're like a hundred hours long.
- What I wanna do for
the next episode is like
the adult manhwa.
- Oh, that's a good one.
- That's a genre I've been getting into.
And honestly,
- Yeah same, same.
- I think adult manhwa, story-wise,
is even better than some doujinshis.
- Yeah, we can recommend
Connor some adult manhwa.
- I feel like Connor would
very much be into adult manhwa.
- Corrupting me slowly.
(Joey laughing)
I'm a man of the Lord,
I've never been corrupted
until today.
- Hey, if you also like to
be corrupted or watch this
episode uncensored, then make
sure to support us on Patreon.
patreon.com/trashtaste
- Look at all of these lovely degenerates.
- Look at all of these lovely degenerates
that are already there,
probably watching this uncensored already.
- For just five beautiful dollars,
you can see all of the glorious
mentions in this video.
- Yeah, you can see all the panels,
all the scenes we talk about.
- The beautiful, beautiful scenes.
- The beautiful scenes, the beautiful art.
- Yeah.
- Oh God.
- But hey, if you enjoy it, then yeah,
make sure to support on Patreon.
Also follow us on Twitter.
Send us your memes on the subreddit,
and if you hate our faces or I mean,
this is gonna be a weird
episode to listen to on Spotify,
but you can listen to
us on Spotify as well.
So go check that out.
- Thank you so much for joining us.
See you later guys. Bye.
- Bye.
- [Garnt] Bye.
(chill wave music begins)